bonjour et bienvenue dans probablement
le podcast qui vivent beaucoup trop
longtemps
bah ça fera une bonne intro frazer par
ses excellents et oui il s'agit ici de
la seconde partie d'une interview
marathon que j'ai fait avec sébastien
qui a duré presque six heures
si vous ne connaissez pas à sébastien
bas à les voir le premier épisode on
parle vraiment de sa vie et de son
oeuvre puisqu'il est notamment docteur
en astrophysique et vulgarisateur
d'exception notamment sur la chaîne
youtube le sense of wonder et dans la
première partie on a justement beaucoup
parlé d'astrophysique et de
vulgarisation maintenance et de seconde
partie on va parler des centres
d'intérêts plus récent de sébastien qui
tournent notamment autour des sciences
de l'environnement
donc sans plus tarder je vous laisse
avec cette seconde partie de l'interview
de sébastien le sait sa part tant que ça
dure un peu aller au bout des idées un
petit peu plus c'est long plus c'est bon
gardien et revenir sur la méthode
scientifique c'est avec grand plaisir
que tu penses avoir appliqué la méthode
scientifique dans ta tête
hu on peut revenir en pause alors oui en
tout cas la vision que la vision que
j'ai de la méthode scientifique alors
c'est difficile hors jeu c'est difficile
de définir la méthode scientifique passe
comment il y en a plusieurs et et voilà
je pense que j'ai utilisé la méthode
scientifique dans le sens où je me suis
servi d'observation j'en ai déduit des
théories qui ont fait des prédictions et
ses prédictions de la théorie je les ai
comparé aux observations
donc à partir de ce nom là pour moi
c'est la définition
facebook de ce que c'est la méthode
scientifique en tout cas la méthode
scientifique de base quoi c'est là qu'on
apprend au lycée sur la prolifique donc
donc la méthode scientifique on appelait
ça la méthode scientifiquement vérifiées
selon pas c'est donc avoir des théories
qui font des prédictions de regarder ses
prédictions correspondent aux données
qui me dire que c'est pas ça c'est sa
femme qui rit je crois que c'est ça en
tout cas à part après j'ai lu le bouquin
de whelan chalme heures d'il ya très
longtemps
qu'est ce que la science qui déconstruit
un peu toutes ces idées voilà il n'ya
pas une notion monolithique de la
méthode scientifique du coup c'est pour
ça que je pensais que je m'attends à ce
que tu me piège sur cette question et du
coup voilà tu peux mettre du coup il est
des vols avant que je te piège je
voudrais les amis trop tard vas-y dis
moi pourquoi j'ai fait non mais j'ai
enfin globalement l'idée je pense que la
formule obeidi de faire ça comment tu
fais ça parce que t'as pas appliqué à
fond le ps mais et puis j'ai passé du
fait ce concert que le bas les indices
je me fais partie à la méthode
scientifique ou l âme est attendu au jeu
s'est passé je sais pas quel point je
corel les deux en pratique
ouais parce qu'en fait pas le ski l'un
des piliers du paysagisme c'est aussi de
dire que tes données disent des choses
objectives sur le monde tu vas tu
considères tu est donné comme quelque
chose de les infos sur le monde sait ça
allait donner
alors qu'en pratique les données est ce
que tu fais ça ce serait un postulat de
plus je pensais à quai le baiia n'est
qu'une facette cette hypothèse est en
tout cas c'est ce que j'avais lu sur ce
jeu jusqu'à présent c'est parce que je
dis quand nous livre times non mes choix
c'est un peu je pense même pas avoir
écrit comme ça mais par le statut de la
donner en fréquente hills mais en
urbaniste s'il n'est pas le même tu vois
c'est par exemple si tu peux appliquer
la formule de bèze et un témoignage
ouais même si c'était mon énergie est
faux et même volontairement mensongère
battu sur pet l'idée c'est de prendre ça
en compte la probabilité donc dans le
vif en temps je parle de l'argument
d'autorité
donc l'argument d'autorité battu peu ça
t'a posé sa commune donnée telle
personne a dit un truc ça sont adonnés
et tu peux appliquer la formule doté de
bayes pour savoir comment ça mais
ajoutée créée dans ce but il suffit
d'appliquer la formule 1 mais on voit ça
comme ça notre petit calculateur 13 sur
nous du coup ça va faire un tel
d'intervenir la probabilité d'avoir
observé la donner sachant que la théorie
tes bras et a profité d'avoir observé
l'ademe et sachant que la théorie était
fausse et physiquement ça ça va inclure
le fait que bacquet a profité sachant
que la théorie tes bras tu pars donc
comprendre le climato sceptisme primates
au changement climatique
c est qu donc si intel dit que le
changement climatique est faux ou
quelque chose comme ça tu vas prendre en
compte sa tu prends un contact après été
qu'une telle de personnes et 10 h en
sachant que je ferais aucun ticket vrai
nom il et puis sachant que sur un an qui
m'a dit qu'il faut moi qui te rends
compte qu'en fait tu bâtis avec moi
aussi c'est quelqu'un qui passe à la
télé c'est un personnage médiatique fait
ces deux probabilité va surtout en
fonction du contexte surtout s'ils ont
voulu opposer deux avis contraire en
fait ces procédés sont également parce
que là pour éviter que quelqu'un qui
passe à la télé
invité à défendre le changement qui met
au scepticisme m'a dit ce qu'ils soient
climato sceptiques en fait ce projet
était également parce qu'ils ont invité
pour sa part dire que même des données
qui sont pas non mais attends je suis en
france je pense est d'accord avec
après pour moi les skis aussi limites
mais les pulsions bayésienne ca d'ordre
quand je suis dans une situation où je
sais absolument rien d'un sujet et que
j'ai pas d'à priori
en fait rien a priori plat que quoique
ça veut dire sur sur un sujet le vrai
bayésiens il te dire eh ben j'ai quand
même un avis sur les questions même si
j'ai jamais vu ça ce phénomène la jupe
arrière ban ali tu je me trompe
peut-être mais j'ai quand même un avis
dessus mais ça dansait dans ce contexte
là j'ai beaucoup plus de mal à former
les opinions sur les choses que je sais
pas et et dans des contextes politiques
par exemple ou dans des contextes
idéologique ultra ultra dur pour moi de
prendre des décisions dans ces dans ces
contextes là surtout dans un contexte où
on te pousse à avoir des décisions parce
que c'est important de prendre d'avoir
une opinion sur tous les sujets de la
société d'aujourd'hui
mais va-t-il point souvent en fait dans
beaucoup de cas la décision que je
recommande c'est d'aller chercher plus
de donner parce qu'il ya encore trop
d'incertitudes et ti france est partie
la formule de l'étendue de son audience
de toute la distribution des profiter
parce qu'elle était la plus crédible et
du coup ça s'est fait avec l approche by
then we elle paraderait gros twin oui je
[Rires]
regarde nous quelle méthode scientifique
comprend pas ce que l'on peut dire que
je regarde les données que je bougeais
minutes tu vois je passais un ordre dans
lequel vous vois ce que tu fous de
l'ordre que tu cherchais de passer un
cycle donc ok faut un petit peu décalée
des données mais donner si c'est des
images du coup je formule des théories
donc des explications qui vont expliquer
des lois sur l'évolution des galaxies
qui font des prédictions ses traditions
ses d'autres images je me prépare des
images des deux images avec les fausses
et après je reproduis ça à l'infini
jusqu'à ce que j'ai pu de financement
mais parce que du coup le jeu je pense
que là où il ya un truc qui va je pense
que d'habitude il ya peut-être deux
choses qui sont un peu problématique
pas dans ton cas avoir cette approche un
peu traître est globale c'est que d'une
part il ya la question de comment tu
fais top quand tu fais ta prédictions
dans doc est en tout cas suffit de
lancer la simulation
ouais mais dans des cas dans notre cas
ça fait plus compliqué travers la
supposant que les théories un peu un peu
vague en déduire les prédictions c'est
un travail difficile dans tous les
domaines des sciences humaines par
exemple faire des prédictions en
sociologie ou faire des tours au ccc
ultra difficile etc des systèmes qui
sont tellement complexes qu'on n'a pas
de loi de loi générale sur comment
évoluent les sociétés il ya certains qui
s'y sont essayés avec quelle valeur a
donné à ça je ne sais pas quoi et puis
il ya toujours un petit peu un risque
étant si les données sont connues avant
de faire du raisonnement motivé de
publier un petit peu notre théorie même
parfois sans s'en rendre compte parce
que c'est un gay cognitifs dont on est
souvent inconscient donc cette cette
partie là c'est souvent assez
problématique par rapport à
l'application en forme j'ai besoin
et puis l'autre partie qui est vraiment
de contentieux entre les défis de notre
attention parce que autant qu'il m'a
expliqué en offrent autant les
spectateurs les auditeurs ne savent pas
voyagé dans golden goal le point où il
ya un désaccord c'est sûr comment est-ce
qu'on compare les données observées avec
les prédictions noës qu'est ce qui va
faire qu'est-ce qu'on prend comme
décision après ça a été une grosse soit
une grosse partie de ma thèse comment
est-ce qu'on compare les faut se donner
les vraies données
je me suis rendu compte que bah en fait
il y à du bricolage
et c'est peut-être là le wait quand tu
me demandait si j'avais vraiment
appliqué la méthode scientifique
j'ai appliqué la méthode scientifique du
mieux que je pouvais mais met en
pratique il n'y avait pas l'outil que je
voulais de comparaison entre des
distributions à plusieurs dimensions
différentes
ça ça n'est que ça n'existe quasiment
pas il faut sélectionner le problème le
réduire au bout d'un moment réduire sa
dimension et a pas parce qu'on fait face
à des contraintes pratiques de de coûts
informatiques et à et c'est super chiant
csu ça c'est super frustrant de se dire
qu'on n'a pas de mesures objectives de
comparer deux choses qui sont au final
pas si éloigné quoi donner d'un côté on
a une image de l'autre on a une autre
image vous dire ça devrait être centre
de les comparer pratique c'est pas
simple ouais c'est 6 6 6 me supérieure
vous imaginez en pratique on a deux
images de galaxies et on veut donner un
nombre
je passais sont distancés sa vraie cette
visite à savoir à quel point ils sont
différents et une approche un peu naïve
qui serait avec marche pas du tout c'est
de comparer pixel par pixel
est ce qu'on fait les soins des images
qu'ils se ressemblent mais en fait les
pixels le pardon de route
enfin si c'est une tournée gaxie qui a
tourné un petit peu une certaine forme
ça se trouve les les plantes deviennent
exactement des noirs et dans le loiret
alors que intuitivement les deux images
se ressemblent on a une mesure de
distance qui est très normes très grande
entrée de exactement et du coup ça msm
est gâchée emploi de de trouver quelle
quelle mesure de distance entre des
données et des prédictions de théories
quelques m distance et pertinente
bah ça je pense pas qu'on ait la réponse
objective à cette question pour
l'instant
moi ce que ce que j'avais cherché dans
les applications à moi enfin ce que
j'avais découvert dans dans mon cas
c'était que quand tu là un espace avec
plein de dimension donc nous on vit dans
un espace à trois dimensions mais il ya
des univers comme vol les paramètres de
db modèles qui sont à 15 dimension à 18
dimensions a plus on augmente la
dimensionnalité du problème plus c'est
difficile pour 2,2 nuages de points qui
vivent dans ces espaces là de déduire
bas quelle est la distance entre ces
deux nuages de points parce que la
notion de distance devient de moins en
moins pertinente à mesure qu'on augmente
la dimensionnalité du problème et
samassa moi ça fait pas mal de nuits
blanches quoi et c'est vraiment un
problème lors d'une machine learning
c'est vraiment des problèmes très
importants à savoir qu'on des espaces de
grandes dimensions sont très bizarre
évoquant sa dimension 25 m oui oui sa
faim direct spa et rudy y survive ou un
million soit sur un drop facile pour les
images brutes
franchement c'était de quelle qualité si
tu regarde les images on est jeté l'idée
en fait je ne l'utilisé pas les images
directement comme donner ce que la cause
est c'est que je prenais mes grandes
images qu'il faisait je n'ai pas un mois
des milliers de pixels sur des milliers
de pixels donc c'est des gros image
quand même et je j'avais des algorithmes
qui détecter automatiquement les
galaxies dans les images
c'est ce que mon directeur de thèse
emmanuel bertin qui avait fait qu'ils
avaient fait ça avec qui très connu pour
ce fameux logiciel qui s'appelle ce
extractor mais oui c'est un petit six
tracteurs
[Rires]
c'est très connu dans la communauté
astronomique parce que c'est très utile
pour détecter des blocs de lumière sur
des sur des images ici ça aide à mettre
le doigt sur le postérieur l'affectera
pas mal utilisé j'ai passé trois ans à
faire des fichiers point sexe
c'était très drôle les trois premières
semaines
et donc voilà c'est très très difficile
donc moi ce que j'avais comme comme
comme donnée à la fin c'était les
propriétés de ces blogs qui était et
éparses extracteur et pas les images
directement c'était une manière de
réduire la dimensionnalité du problème
au lieu de le faire mille 1000 pixels x
1000 pixels donc un terme de
dimensionnalité s'était pas qui sait par
contre c'est elle s'était plus tôt où
sont les blocs de lumière et c'est pas
facile à trouver les blogs de mire parce
que c'est parfois le bruit sur l'image
va créer me développe de lumière donc
savoir distinguer un bruit d'une galaxie
c'est pas simple et comme on le faisait
aussi dans les fossés image finale ça va
donc on comparait les oranje avec les
oranje avaient par les oranje avec les
ornithorynques ouais voilà donc parce
que dans des cas pratiques mesurer des
distances entre une prédiction une vraie
données sap est très pompiers nous la
donner des images encore on peut se dire
les images bon ça vient malheureusement
peut-être après ta thèse maintenant il
ya les réseaux de neurones qui qui font
ça ni moi encore que j'ai servi à rien
[Rires]
td a vraiment eu de timing même
l'histoire des sciences wade aux
provinces en grands moments de l'année
après dans d'autres cas aussi il est
question qu'est-ce qu'on fait aussi
une distance comme ça donc toi tu t'es
passé dans un cadre un coach et monte
carlo où tu as ta télé c'est cette
exploration a du coup tu trouvé le les
briques et toutes les bonnes propriétés
le postérieur à tous à blackburn a parlé
mais dans d'autres cas les gens autant
sa puce vouloir rejeter des théories oui
ce que tu penses que tu as cherché à en
rejeter les théories en fait je n'en ai
pas rejeter je les ai toutes mes
théories sont incluses dans mon
postérieur à la suite j'ai foutu toutes
mes théories dans mon postérieur
c'est le truc le plus bayésiens que j'ai
jamais dis et je me sens très mal à
l'aise et voit la base de ce dont je ne
sais pas je les ai pas le voter quoi
mais c'est juste que parfois on les voit
on les voit pas on voit pas les théories
les moins probables
du coup c'est comme si on les avait
rejetés au final mais on y voit pas
parce qu'elles n'apparaissent pas dans
la visualisation de mes graphiques de
postérieurs ouais voilà tout à lui gardé
les plus grosses pourtant postérieur
alors les atouts de faire une chose la
plus stupide menant de deux mecs super
diplômés
je l'aï entendu ces intersections de
données dans ce jeu est un pote
donc non ça c'est autre chose
oui fini avec la méthode scientifique a
raconté avec tant de classe et d'une
élégance
donc après tout a commencé donc tu t'es
un set intéressé à d'autres sujets
est-ce que tu as commencé à s'intéresser
au dessus 6 au dessus et parenthèse ou
widi
toujours au grand désarroi des
directeurs et quelles sont ses sujets
voilà ces sujets c'est les sciences du
système terre ces sujets c'est toutes
les sciences de notre de notre impact
sur sur la planète depuis depuis le
début de ma thèse j'ai développé une
espèce de conscience écologique parce
que j'ai lu pas mal de pas mal
d'ouvragés de scientifiques qui bossait
sur sur ces questions là des
environnementalistes des années 70 et
ses annonces à forger une espèce de
conscience écologique et de volonté de
comprendre notre interaction avec le
système terre donc cela terre c'est un
système complexe et nos sociétés
agissent sur ce système terre et le
système terre agit en retour sur sur nos
sociétés
donc pour moi ça me paraît important que
je réfléchisse quand même beaucoup dans
mon coin un papa pas forcément
publiquement mais dans mon coin
qu'est-ce que ça à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler une bonne société une société
qui dure qui dure longtemps qu'il soit
stable et qui minimise les inégalités
les souffrances des gens enfin voilà des
gens et les animaux enfin voilà et et sa
masse et des lectures qui m'ont beaucoup
parlé et est donc depuis je m'intéresse
pas mal à tous qui dit anthropocène tout
ce qui m'a l'assurance du système terre
et depuis plus récemment comment les
sociétés évoluent avec un point de vue
anthropologique historique sociologique
voilà je m'intéresse pas mal aussi aux
sciences humaines depuis quelques années
et d'une manière que j'espère un peu
approfondis parce que je prends des
coups en fait c'est des cours de
plusieurs plusieurs dizaines d'heures à
chaque fois et c'est mon occupation
depuis maintenant plusieurs de trois ans
de faire ça le plus possible et
d'essayer de d'engranger une espèce de
point de vue interdisciplinaire sur le
monde avec les limites que ça bien sûr
je le fais avec
j'essaie de le faire avec beaucoup
d'humilité et pas de pouvoir de sortir
avec mon mon chapeau de physiciens d un
bon jour je me suis je suis au dessus de
vous tous et j'ai la meilleure
description du monde mais pour tout le
reste c'est des dérivés de la physique
j'ai créé j'estime que j'ai créé assez
ça sans me l'univers écoutez ça laisse
pas impressionner avec votre un univers
j'aimerais qu'on me pique quoi tu en
voilà si à l'échelle du caucus depuis
toujours sur les big boys tu as
d'ailleurs fait c'est vraiment mon
obsession du moment les big white cannes
et l'hélico sncf voilà d'où est ce qu on
vient où est ce qu'on va
et qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de bien en tant qu en tant
qu'espèce et entre deux sociétés
et ça c'est des questions qui me voient
qu'ils me donnent un sens en ce moment
c'est mon fils et mon fils directeurs du
moment et ça me tient depuis depuis
quelques années et et voilà donc pour
l'instant j'en suis là ça va déboucher
accueil à quoi tout ça ça va déboucher
sur un bouquin quels sont vos projets
non mais 2020 qui traite qui très clair
je sais pas encore comment ça va
s'appeler mais l'idée c'est de ces de
reconstruire tous les liens invisibles
que la science a révélé entre nous et le
reste de l'univers entre l'univers
lui-même et et nous l'idée c'est d'avoir
ce une approche vraiment scientifique
donc qui s'approche le plus de ce qu'on
considère être le consensus scientifique
actuelle sur sequana description du
monde et ça va dire voilà on est
composée d'atomes d'où viennent nos
atomes
on est composé de molécules donc d'où
viennent ces molécules on est vivant
donc qu'est ce qui nous relie au vivant
donc comment est-ce que c'est bien this
le cosmos notice nous et comment nous
est-ce qu'on tisse des liens entre nous
génétiquement culturellement et comment
ces liens se vont se défaire au bout
d'un moment parce que la complexité dans
l'univers elle peut pas perdurer pour
toujours donc c'est aussi un bouquin qui
va perdre l'aide de la mort thermique de
l'univers de la mort de l'univers et
l'idée c'est d'avoir là je me suis dit
pour un premier bouquin vous être humble
jeu sur un sujet qu'on maîtrise donc je
vais parler de l'histoire de l'humanité
depuis le big bang jusqu'à la mort de
l'univers voilà on va faire simple pour
coudre src et jusqu'à présent je pense
que depuis la fin de l'été je suis
rentré dans la période la plus riche
intellectuellement de ma vie même après
ma tête c'était pas aussi riche
intellectuellement quoi parce que au
final ans que j'étais sur un domaine
très très très restreint à une sous
question en dessous question l'âge
toutes les semaines je me plonge dans
une science différentes et j'essaie d'en
apprendre quelque chose
et d'en déduire un espèce de discours
cohérent et pas plus cohérent qu'il le
dit parce que sinon ça serait malhonnête
il n'y a pas de consensus sur une
question je vais pas inventer un
consensus moi même et je trouve que
c'est important pour la pour la
construction de mon identité déjà dire
bah qui est ce que moi je suis dans et
quelles qu'elles sont mais mes liens
avec le reste du monde mais aussi
quelles sont les clés de notre place
dans l'univers 1 qu'elle sait quoi notre
champ d'action qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut
pas faire et qu'est ce qui est
inévitable
quoi mais à partir de ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui je pense que ça enfin c'est
des idées que moi j'aimerais les voir
répandre dans l'eau dans la sphère
publique
déjà parce que on vit dans un monde qui
est assez fragmenté en terme social en
termes même en termes disciplinaires
généralement les gens qui se considèrent
littéraire ou qui sont plus proches des
sciences humaines avoir pas avoir une
culture scientifique des sciences dures
et inversement
donc c'est quelque chose que j'aimerais
rapprocher promouvoir une certaine
vision de l'interdisciplinarité et
comment différentes visions du monde
peuvent être complémentaires pour quand
des tubes i un même système d'avoir une
vision un peu ça promet aussi une vision
systémique du monde c'est quelque chose
que je trouve vraiment primordial si on
veut penser le monde de manière la plus
rationnelle possible c'est qu'on ait des
systèmes complexes qui on est des
systèmes qui sont beaucoup plus complexe
que ce que nous on peut comprendre mais
ces systèmes ont aussi les dynamiques
qu'on peut essayer de prédire avec un
certain degré de précision des systèmes
complexes comme des galaxies les
systèmes complexes comme des écosystèmes
tout ça lg agissent selon dd des
dynamiques propres et si on veut agir
sur une société par exemple je
m'intéresse pas mal à comment est-ce
qu'on peut agir sur une société de
manière efficace et bien il faut prendre
en compte que on peut pas tout faire
qu'on ne peut pas changer une société
peut pas même s'ils ont fait la
révolution demain changer une société
dans ses fondements ça va pas prendre
dix ans ça va pas prendre cinq ans ça va
prendre un an ça va prendre
il ya une inertie danser dans ce système
là et prendre en compte ces inertie
c'est important si on veut créer une
bonne société de savoir à quelle échelle
de temps agit tel ou tel système est de
se dire de reconstruire ses liens qui
sont souvent invisibles et qu'on ne voit
pas et et que la science nous aident à a
révélé pour moi c'est super important si
on veut agir sur le monde de manière
bénéfique et donc ça donc ça c'est la
première étape de mon plan de domination
du monde c'est d'écrire un bouquin est
la deuxième étape c'est de construire un
court autour de noël toutes ces notions
là parce que depuis deux ans j'ai
accumulé énormément de
de connaissances sur ces sujets là et je
me rends compte que à moi tout seul
c'est super frustrant de garder tous et
toutes vos infos qui qui ont changé
d'avis et de dire merde
maintenant je suis le seul porteur de
cette connaissance intégrée elle alors
ça c'est ça c'est super super autant de
dire ça mais je dirais qu'ils accusent
de l'uqtr radiateur c'est un truc de
bulgari a des racines ont vulgarisé
c'est parce que ce sont un peu frustrés
le fait de l'expliquer ça permet de
mieux le comprendre aussi c est une
notion un peu égoïste dans la
vulgarisation qui est si tu veux
vraiment le comprendre il faut
l'enseigner
et ça c'est vraiment ça fait parti d'un
désir très personnelle de vouloir
comprendre le monde de manière la plus
intégrée possible et de promouvoir
certaines idées une vision scientifique
du monde donc je pense que moi c'est un
but de vie que je me suis je me suis
donné quelques années notamment avec
kindle il ya l'événement qui a changé
mairie à ce niveau là c'était une
conférence ted
alors on dit que on dira ce qu'on veut
des têtes et je suis le premier à
critiquer les ted mais il ya un thème
qui a changé ma vie
c'est un ted d'un historien qui
s'attelle david christiane et la ligue
christiane il a fait ça ce merveilleux
talent qui s'appelle l'histoire du monde
en 18 minutes et son idée à lui s'est il
a monté un an domaine académique qui
s'appelle la ligue history et la libye
story c'est un truc qui existe depuis
les débuts des années 2000 qui
essentiellement un mouvement anglo
saxons interdisciplinaire avec plein de
chercheurs de plein de disciplines
des biologistes et géologues des gens
qui font des sciences humaines
des anthropologues etc qui se réunissent
régulièrement et qui vont et leur fils
directeurs sait comment est-ce qu'on
peut raconter l'histoire de l'humanité
de la manière la plus complète possible
et la plus fiable et l'idée c'est de
faire parler ces chercheurs qui se
parlent pas d'habitude et d'encre et
d'en faire une histoire une histoire qui
est ensuite répandu avec avec des cours
ils ont créé des moûts qu'ils ont créé
un truc qui était financée par bill
gates et ils ont créé des classes des
classes de lycées afin d'aider des cours
de lycée qui ont été implémentées dans
certains dans certaines classes tests
aux états unis et voilà c'est une vision
que j'ai trouvé absolument génial parce
qu'elle est très très intégrée elle
promeut diversité des points de vue elle
promeut elle dépasse en fait c'est une
histoire qui se focalise qui a une qui
suit une tradition historique parce que
à la base à la base de tout ce mouvement
là il à fernand braudel qui était un
historien du xxème siècle qui a lancé
une école d'historiographie qui
s'appelle les annales et l'école des
annales en fête son but c'est pas de se
focaliser sur les grands personnages de
l'histoire où les changements en
institutions etc
c'était de se concentrer sur les longues
durées ça c'est une expérience avec une
une affirmation
une expression qui a fait date dans
l'histoire de l'histoire c'est de ce
pont d'un point de vue de dire nos
sociétés elles agissent à plein de plein
des échelles différentes notamment aux
longues durées donc notre histoire c'est
pas juste une histoire des nations
l'histoire des nations ça existe depuis
le 19e siècle et avant elle n'est pas de
concept de nation donc il faut trouver
une autre manière de décrire une société
et il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui là l'une
des seules manières dont on apprend
l'histoire en tout cas à l'école c'est
voilà c'est l'histoire de france c'est à
dire voilà on serait trop les gaulois on
a des histoires nationales et des romans
nationaux parfois et je trouve que c'est
une histoire qui focalise une espèce de
d'approché très communautariste de notre
identité de dire à moi je me considère
français non moi je me considère
britannique mais moi je me considère
américain est en fait on vit dans une
société aujourd'hui oui liebenstein
société qui se fragmente dans le sens où
les nationalismes grandissent de plus en
plus en moi sa voix c'est quelque chose
qui m'inquiète en personne et moralement
la montée des nationalismes parce que
c'est pas ce dont on a besoin en ce
moment où on a besoin de se rassembler
sur des problèmes communs qui dépasse
les frontières et je trouve que c'est
une vision du monde que j'aime bien quoi
qui part d'une certaine communauté de
gens qui essayent de construire un récit
qui dépasse les frontières et qui essaie
de créer une espèce d'identité
planétaire l'identité cosmique allongé
valançon les grands thermes faisons
montons une nouvelle religion non mais
mais voilà l'idée c'est de c'est ce que
ce que le quart sagan appelle la
perspective cosmique quoi de dire de se
penser en termes d' individus comme
comme influente avec plusieurs échelles
sur lesquelles on peut voir le monde
comprendre le monde et donc voilà ça
c'est ça sautait a changé ma vie et
depuis
alors au début j'avais contacté les gens
qui sont derrière la le bistouri
procheck je leur ai dit c'est tellement
génial votre projet est ce que je peux
le traduire en français gratuitement
j'ai eu de réponse et du coup ça il ya
alors une station chez moi et j'ai envie
enfin j'ai eu envie d'en faire quelque
chose et la manière dont j'ai trouvé
pour en faire quelque chose en tout cas
pour initier quelque chose c'est d'en
faire un bouquin et
et pour l'instant ça anime toutes mes
journées de temps libre depuis deux ans
maintenant et on verra ce qu'on va faire
plus tard il sera gros comme on le sait
pas alors j'ai dit à mon éditeur que ce
serait entre 200 et 400 pages
mais c'est vrai que mes notes en ce
moment font plus de 500 pages déjà donc
bah va falloir élaguer des trucs et du
coup tu as parlé de deux enseignants
d'un cours par rapport à tout ça ouais
alors c'est très c'est très préliminaire
comme idée je ne sais pas où je vais le
donner et je sais pas aussi l'univers me
laissera à donner au secours parce que
d'un cours qui n'existe pas en france en
fait c'est vraiment des idées que j'ai
c'est de ramener du monde anglo saxon en
france et je vois certaines personnes
qui commencent à avoir ce genre d'idées
notamment en histoire environnemental on
a des gens comme laurent testo avec son
histoire globale qui est une sous
section de l'histoire mais qui peut être
relié à la bim history aussi donc c'est
des visions qui me parle et j'ai envie
de contacter ces gens pour leur dire à
quel point j'ai envie de faire des
choses avec vous non sexuel et voilà
rester avec eux c'est extra j'avais
utilisé ces extracteurs avec vous donc
pour moi c'est une manière aussi de
garder les pieds dans un milieu
académique
voilà j'ai passé deux ans maintenant
hors du milieu académique mais à me
former sur d'autres sciences de manière
la plus rigoureuse que je puisse après
l'idée c'est de me faire relire aussi
par des experts de chaque domaine que je
vais
que je vais traiter parce que je connais
trop bien le biais du de l'intellectuel
public qui va écrire au delà de son
domaine d'expertisé qui va dire des gros
bullshit à plein de la plein de gens je
sais c'est un de mes pires cauchemars je
veux pas devenir comme ce à quoi je
connais trop d'intellectuels publics qui
sont dans ces énoncés travers la voix
qui vous regarde mais c'est ça c'est
vraiment le truc que je vais vite avec
moi dans mes productions dans des idées
que j'essaie de promouvoir j'essaie de
garder cette humilité systémique et
l'unité académique qui fait que je vais
pas annoncer quelque chose sans pouvoir
le site et citer la source de ce que
j'affirme que je vais pas balancer des
chiffres voilà 90% des gens qui
balancent des chiffres ont tort
généralement c'est 95% des statistiques
soient montés sur exactement donc donc
voilà donc peut-être un court parce que
j'accumule des trucs peut-être un site
internet là pour l'instant j'accumule
pas mal de tout ce que j'accumule là
j'essaie de le mettre en forme sur un
format qui ne va pas être mon bouquin
mais qui peut être utile pour plus tard
avec toutes mes ressources à tous les
liens tous les liens tous les bouquins
jolly
tous les documentaires tous les surtout
des bouquins je lis enfin les
documentaires des sources secondaires
qui sont rarement rarement fiable mais
ça m'empêche pas avoir regardé parce que
ça te donne une idée de ce qu'est ce que
les gens considèrent que qui est
important ou pas mais voilà pour
l'instant j'en suis là bon on verra ce
que ça donne après grand rendez vous
dans deux ans podcast de 5 heures ce
sera calme et du coup l'accession encore
plus grandes banques gardent pour
l'instant c'est mon obsession quoi c'est
du coup quels sont les trucs les plus
quelques trucs par mini truqué plus
agréable que tu as découvert en france
et on cherche les trucs les plus
incroyables que j'ai découvert nous
importe à quoi bon aller plus des trucs
les plus importants c'est à quel point
par exemple on a
on a altéré en altérer la phase de la
face du monde voilà moi j'ai lu pas mal
d'articles ou de bouquins de gens qui
sont dans la rue dans la commission
scientifique pour définir l'anthropocène
et les trucs les plus importants que
j'ai lu c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
là quoi de se dire que la moitié des
paysages sur terre a été altérée
directement par par an par l'humanité
motif j'ai la moitié nord
elle tirait directement la indirectement
c'est l'intégralité de la surface du
bois de se dire qu on a altéré
l'atmosphère en balançant de non
seulement des gaz à effet de serre mais
aussi en altérant certains cycles
biogéochimiques c'est à dire les changes
des éléments chimiques sur la terre on a
balancé des aérosols un peu partout ont
perturbé un système qui est qui va se
mettre progressivement dans un autre
état d' équilibre qui est peut-être
moins habitable que ce qu'on voudrait et
ce serait ce serait dommage peut surtout
qu'on comprend ce qui se passe en tout
cas une certaine une certaine échelle et
je trouve que voilà les les sciences du
système terre en général sont pas assez
connus dans le bon camp public c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais vraiment
promouvoir plus que plus que les
galaxies et les étoiles c'est pour moi
c'est les planètes le grand le grand
rond point focal qui m'anime aujourd'hui
quoi de savoir les planètes ça
fonctionne une planète
est ce que la terre en quoi est ce que
la terre à différentes des autres
planètes qu'est-ce qui a fait que bayer
de la vie qu'est apparue sur la terre ou
pas c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
quand même de savoir
je suis pas mal de cours d'exane
biologie il ya quelques mois donc la
science de la vie dans l'univers
et là j'ai appris énormément de trucs
quoi sur sur les hypothèses de
de l'origine de la vie sur le monde à
arn sur les différentes étapes qui ont
fait que la vie elle est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
mais elle aurait pu le prendre un chemin
différent s'il n'y avait pas eu ces
trucs là un des trucs que j'ai appris
que j'ai trouvé ça vachement vachement
intéressant c'est que on n'est pas la
première espèce a balancé nos déchets et
à avoir un impact global sur la planète
par exemple si on prend il ya 2 5
milliards d'années à la moitié de l'âge
de la terre à peu près la plupart des
formes de vie sur terre cd des formes
très simple des organismes
unicellulaires c'est des bactéries et il
ya eu un moment où certaines souches de
bactéries ont développé une innovation
un peu par hasard et qui leur permettait
de capter la lumière du soleil et
c'était une invention de la
photosynthèse
alors il ya eu quelques quelques essais
infructueux pendant un moment on voit le
niveau de certains éléments chimiques
but i qui monte et qui revêt ce moment
pendant quelques temps et puis au bout
d'un moment c'est une adaptation qui est
super g super efficace et qui permet à
ces populations de bactéries
photosynthétiques d'exploser et le
problème que ça a eu c'est que la
photosynthèse saab a lancé un déchet ce
déchet c'est l'oxygène et il se trouve
que l'oxygène il n'existait pas dans le
dans l'atmosphère de la terre à cette
époque là et la majorité de la vie qui
s'est développée depuis depuis un
milliard d'années elle n'est pas trop
l'oxygène c'est l'oxygène c'est le truc
qui rouillent c'est le tout-petit brûle
et en fait ça a créé espèce d'holocauste
on appelait la grande oxydation qui a
holocauste et je sais pas si ça se dit
holocaust and génocide et une grande
partie de la vie de surface sur un sur
la planète surface marine parce que la
vie était essentiellement marine à ces
époques la fin complètement marine est
en fait aujourd'hui voir s'ils ont
complètement changé la face de la terre
parce que s'il ya de l'oxygène
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il ya de la
vie il avait planète aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont la plupart des planètes qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui non pas d'oxygène
dans leur atmosphère quoi donc c'est si
on découvre un jour dans l'atmosphère
d'une exoplanète de l'oxygène verra
vraiment regarder de près cette planète
là parce que il passerait peut-être un
truc qui serait intéressant à voir donc
ça c'est un des trucs que j'ai appris
que je trouve vraiment important c'est
que on a des leçons de l'histoire qu'on
peut utiliser là dedans donc on n'est
pas la première espèce à avoir un impact
global on n'est pas la première espèce
qu'on n'est pas la seule espèce à
utiliser par on a tendance à être très
entrepôts centres et dans notre manière
de voir les choses et il ya des choses
qui ont été développées indépendamment
par d'autres espèces de trucs qu'on
pense être le propre de l'homme par
exemple l'utilisation du feu c'est un
truc que nous on se vante d'avoir
maîtrisé parce que voilà le feu ça nous
a permis de cuire des aliments ça nous a
permis de grandir notre cerveau on est
très content de ça le fun et c'est cool
puis ça permet de réchauffer mais
certains oiseaux utilisent le feu comme
une stratégie de chasse donc les
premiers feux de forêt c'est pas les
humains qu'ils ont fait c'est ça des
oiseaux jeu
et bien c'est bien ils vont prendre un
feu qui est déjà acquis est déjà là il
comprend des petites brindilles hockey
et ils vont les mettre ailleurs là où
ils veulent manger pour faire fuir les
leur victime pour qu'ils soient plus
facilement trouvable parce que s'ils
sont dans des arbres ils seront ils sont
facilement trouvables ils ont pas
facilement trouvable et techniques de
chasse du wes et des techniques de
chasse qui ont une espèce de corps
évolution fin de l' évolution
convergente qui a fait que certains
traits l'agriculture on n'est pas les
premiers à avoir inventé l'agriculture
certaines certaines fourmis montrèrent
des pucerons et donc ont utilisé des
domestiques à vont cultiver des
champignons ça c'est un truc que je
trouve absolument fou et l'idée c'est de
savoir laquelle
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui fait notre
particularité dans tout ça alors les
gens qui font david history ils ont un
point de vue c'est que ce qui
différencie l'humain des autres espèces
c'est l'apprentissage collectif c'est le
fait que au fil des générations
on apprend de plus en plus de choses que
contrairement à la plupart des animaux
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui qui certes
enseigne certains ce qu'ils certains
certaines compétences à d'autres alors à
leur progéniture mais ça va jamais si
c'est pas de la connaissance qui va être
accumulative et donc on est a priori les
seuls à faire ça jusqu'à présent il n'y
a pas même des cultures a prise dans pas
mal il ya des cultures les animaux mais
c'est des cultures qui sont pas
cumulatives c'est à dire que c'est pas
des pas des innovations qui vont être
créées qui vont être enseignée
e
qui vont être enseignée sur sur
plusieurs générations il est c'est que
on a on a par exemple des dauphins qui
qui se grattent mutuellement le dos avec
des éponges
donc ça c'est l'utilisation d'outils
donc on n'est pas les seuls à utiliser
des outils aussi c'est un certain
corbeau qui utilisent des méta outil
c'est à dire qu'ils vont utiliser des
outils comme des brindilles pour pouvoir
aller chercher d'autres outils donc ça
prouve qu'il ya une une condition
animale qui est vraiment fantastique
quoi et mais plus on en découvre
évidemment moins on découvre qu'on est
spécial sur la planète par contre ce
qu'on découvre c'est qu'on est les
premiers à être conscients des
changements qu'on fait sur la planète et
ça le fil le planétologue david green
school qui a écrit un excellent bouc est
un sujet qui s'appelle leur fille
newell's 10 mois et un bouquin qui a été
complètement renversant dans ma
construction à ce niveau là c'est de se
dire on vit peut-être une époque sans
précédent dans l'histoire de la terre et
c'est la première fois depuis 4 5
milliards d'années que la terre est
consciente qu'elle existe en tant que
terre et que et qu'il ya quelque chose à
sa surface qui peut détruire un
équilibre qui étaient déjà là donc on
est la première espèce qui est
consciente des déchets que ces déchets
ont un impact global et je pense que
l'on peut être aussi la première espèce
à prendre conscience qu'on est une
inhumanité globale et parce que ça fait
pas longtemps qu'on se voit comme une
humanité et globale
historiquement c'est super super récents
mais ça pas encore imprégné les cultures
quoi c'est on est toujours sûr sur des
récits nationaux france
je suis en train de réfléchir premières
traces de d'universalité comme ça il y
avait un philosophe chinois je suis
comment s'appelle retient jamais non
mais qui du coup avait devancé van lang
rôle perte de 8,8 à rythmes ouais chine
et qui du coup avait cette vision
l'humanité on sera ensemble assez rare
fois après l'âge
j'imagine qu'après quand j'ai commencé à
voir des voyages internationaux
deschamps n'a pas forcément parce que
tout ce qui dit une colonisation au 19e
siècle
d'ailleurs on était dans un processus de
déshumanisation des autres cultures tu
vois et mêmes même pas tu prends la
deuxième guerre mondiale l'extermination
l'extermination des juifs
je suis désolé tu avais démonétisation
10 mai mais ce n'est pas mon idée
c'était c'était de déshumaniser ces gens
là et à chaque fois qu'on a une guerre
le fait qu'on ait des guerres encore
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est capable de
considérer d'autres gens comme des non
humains sinon on ne le ferait pas il ya
très peu de temps paul blum que sur
patients de son prénom est celui qui a
écrit ça s'appelle le ghana c'est donc
contre la rage et il a écrit à je peux
si je crois qu'ils entendent écrire au
niveau profil est passé sur michael vick
technique et on parie entendu parler ou
il parle souvent du fait qu'au contraire
c'est qui fait les tensions
géopolitiques
c'est le fait qu'on humanise le
composent et away si on considère que
les autres juste des machines et que je
n'avais pas une tension enfin en fait
c'est puis se voit en fait quand on se
rend compte qu'il ya un coupable par
exemple vrai nom lui veut du mal quand
ça va probablement quand c'est la faute
à pas de chance ou une machine moins dix
patrons on n'a pas cet énervement cette
colère et cette envie de causer du mal
d'un accord intéressant
1 il pensait passer parce que j'ai lu
jusqu'à présent mais
je lirai du coup vous cacher j'ai pas eu
bien distincts écoutez mindscape
ah oui et non mais c'est une position
que je sois intéressante parce que on a
fait une vision beaucoup plus enfin via
la théorie des jeux et un peu mécanique
les gens là il ya des intérêts
individuels d'activité notamment dans le
cas de la politique ça permet de vendre
deux de calmer les choses qu'avant
combat si tu te mets ont parlé de
greenpeace tout à l'heure j'ai ma place
de greenpeace fin c'est compliqué est ce
que c'est une grosse structure il ya pas
mal de l'adhérent dedans qui ont des
avis très contraire et puis là ils ont
une image publique
ils ont quand même intérêt intéressants
s'ils veulent promouvoir l'écologie à
rester gros une certaine influence du
coup changé notamment par exemple à
cause de profils scientifiques certaines
positions c'est compliqué cote est de
vous si tu désires cette vision très
très humanisante en disant mais c'est
ici quand ils peuvent ne pas voir les
choses
ça peut être un frein au dialogue que tu
vas voir avec une piste alors si si
cette vision un peu mécanique c'est
juste et des cheveux sont des agents
avec un objectif chacun et maximise les
choses nous paraît avoir ce même vision
pour les entreprises se prend pour toute
structure complexe d'ailleurs moi mais
je pense que tu t'es tu peux pas élaguer
le fait que derrière ces structures il
ya aussi des humains et est en fait les
structures or on me les forges les
humains en partie et les humains forgent
les structures aussi donc il ya des
liens qui se font entre différents
niveaux d'un système si tu veux vraiment
comprendre le système tu es obligé
d'avoir les deux approches comme j'ai
d'avoir l'approché humaniste et la
proche théorie des jeux et d'autres
approches aussi une approche historique
une logique et pression de la poche me
disant tu
malin si tu doit interagir avec des
jantes à les considérer comme des gens
comme des agents avec leurs propres
intérêts alors propos n'étaient pas
obligées de l'ordre et d'insister sur le
fait qu' il ils ont une humanité par
exemple je suis pas forcément d'accord
pourquoi après on peut en débattre
enfin moi je n'ai pas plus de waimes
saison ses rangs la position de paul
blum choix que je trouve assez
convaincante
c'est aussi un des trucs on dit pardon
livre feeling good way c'est un peu cet
essai cette approche de de se dire de
tendresse qu'on a un peu un réflexe en
fait qui qui est de dire que si l'autre
est humain il doit agir de certains
manière un peu un fait que c'est un peu
déontologique il ça devrait se passer
comme ça parce qu'il est alors que si on
a aussi requis lautner considèrent qu'on
ne donne pas trop d'importance au fait
que l'autre soit humain n'a - cette
exigence envers l'autre qui est du coup
peut potentiellement le plus
bienveillant corps vers l'autre ouais
c'est cette différence entre eux on
parle un peu avec juliette à la
différence entre empathie cognitive et
on peut en pâtir et émotionnel en pâtit
émotionnel on va essayer de ressentir
l'autre faire sentir que l'autre est
humain et en fait ça ça peut augmenter
les tensions alors que les mots
l'empathie et cognitif ça serait juste
essayer de comprendre ce que ce que
l'autre pense m et mince avant
l'empathie émotionnel c'est aussi de se
mettre à la place de l'autre donc ça
veut dire temporairement suspendre son
jugement pour se mettre à la place de
l'autre bailly émotionnel c'est plus
ressentir l'émotion de l'autre ouais
mais mais pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui est vachement positif en tout cas
dans la majorité des cas que je vois une
empathie par développer son cercle
d'empathie augmenter son certaine
empathie ça ça aurait des impacts
positifs qu'on va dire ben typiquement
le cas le chaos du genre de l'empathie
cognitives me semble
jean tati émotionnel me semble très
problématique c'est le cas dans des bars
unis mais que dirait qu'on sent que
l'autre énervé si on a de l'empathie
émotionnel on a tendance à vouloir
sentir ce que l'autre s'en va se mettre
sur le web et par moi j'ai joué dans
cette situation j'aurais eu le réflexe
inverse si tu veux comme une horreur des
conflits en général là les choses de
très viscéral chez moi si je vois que la
personne commence à s'énerver je vais
essayer de calmer le jeu pour l'envoyer
sur quelque chose qu'ils le resteraient
sur le sur le même sujet si tu veux mais
avec une approche différente parce que
je vois que cette approche et les
clientes et moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant dans le cadre d'un débat
public ou dans un débat en général de
prendre en compte l'état émotionnel de
la personne pour favoriser un débat sain
et rationnelle quoi parce que oui oui
mais l'empathie collectif cherche à
faire cela oui ils avaient un compte
bancaire dans tatie émotionnel l'idée
c'est que tu ressens l'émotion de
l'autre et ça va se sont blum et ça me
paraît très peu de temps c'est en fait
généralement indésirables comme du
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas de jeu pas
d'avis là dessus exemple quand on parle
avec juliette c'est quelqu'un qui est un
patient qui est paniqué ben vaut mieux
que le médecin soit pas paniqué bien sûr
la science même mais savoir qu en fait
pour moi la notion d'empathie que je
mettais en sous couvert c'était savoir
dans quel état est la personne bon ça
c'est ce que tu m'aies d'empathie
cognitive et l'impression mais voilà
deux de ce pouvoir se projeter dans la
personne pour se dire cette personne
ressent ça en ce moment
cette émotion elle est très négative et
si j'agis sur cette personne je dois
prendre en compte cette information là
et si on faisait ça dans plein de
contexte je pense qu'on serait dans un
trou dans une meilleure société
mais c'est sa séparation n'a plus à
l'empathie cognitive d'accord le feng la
grande critique que fait problème c'est
qui est souvent une confusion entre les
deux mondes au world accord bonjour
l'empathie tu fus quand tu peux pas
ressentir ce que votre sang en fait
c'est plutôt une bonne chose ne pas
ressentir ce que l'autre ressent hockey
soit six autres sont une passion faut
pas une passion pour les battre il ya
toujours des exceptions qui t'arrange
c'est exactement ce que racontait
parce que je disais david bowers
feelgood c'est choisir les émotions
est-ce que est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose que je reçoive le ressentent cette
émotion
oui et non pas forcément accepté
l'émotion ressentir l'émotion de l'autre
aussi l'autre ont énervé un truc que je
trouvais intéressant à méditer est ce
que ça vaut vraiment le coup de
ressentir les émotions de l'autre ou est
ce que vraiment considérer l'autre comme
comme quelque chose potentiel à un peu
mécanique mais dont on veut le bien peut
vouloir le bien de quelque chose qui est
mécanique est aussi par mois je dans la
manière dont je le développe s était
plutôt en réaction à des événements
historiques qui ont eu un impact très
négatif elles de se dire on est on est
notre notre groupe d'humains et plus
haut que les autres groupes d'humains et
du coup on va s'en servir pour les
exploiter pour en faire des choses
innommables pendant pour une grande
partie de l'histoire de l'humanité mais
ça a mené l'esclavagé ça a amené le
racisme ça amenait pas mal de pas mal de
choses qu'on veut pas dans une société
en général je me serais je pas si c'est
vraiment le des causes basé ses 46
justifier comme ça en tout cas ouais
c'était justifié comme ça mais c'est
peut-être un raisonnement motivé comme
c'est juste que oui bien sûr mais aussi
pratique d'amendé au club du coup quelle
que soit la cause de départ et ce grâce
à des causes économiques
c'est d'une pause on a besoin de vos
terres donc
on va vous envahir et après on va se
servir vous comme esclaves ou voilà part
souvent c'est des raisonnements
économiques qui la colonisation des
européens par exemple on peut partir de
cet exemple au xviiie siècle elle est en
partie dû au fait que l'europe l'avait
déforester une énorme partie de son
territoire et elle cherchait des
manières de produire de produire plus
quoi de soutenir son agriculture et pour
ça il fallait des nouvelles terres et
d'être donc c'est là où ils sont ils ont
débarqué au ils ont débarqué le un peu
un peu partout ailleurs aux états unis
etc et ont commencé à coloniser et à
justifier l'exploitation d'autres
d'autres humains des populations locales
en afrique etc
pour sûr sur des bases qui aujourd'hui
ne tiennent plus mais voilà sur des
bases on va vous on à la supériorité
morale on va donc c'est normal qu'on
fasse ça c'est pour votre bien en finale
et puis il ya une certaine une certaine
nature qui est à l'oeuvre et la nature
elle fait bien les choses donc voila
nous en tant qu'européens on est on est
meilleur que tous les autres et ça c'est
un raisonnement qui est ultra dangereux
et je pense que si on doit prendre des
leçons du passé on doit s'intéresser au
passé et
et de voir dans quel contexte ces
idées-là ont émergé et même si les
raisonnements était motivé au départ le
fait que ça a été ensuite ça ensuite
perdurer au delà des ex des aspects
économiques et politiques cécité le
racisme ça existe toujours aujourd'hui
en tant que reliques des premiers temps
de la colonisation sinon ça n'existerait
pas sur la sous la forme on l'a
aujourd'hui les les résultats du racisme
ils sont toujours visibles quoi ils sont
visibles institutionnellement ils sont
visibles économiquement et dans l'est
dans toutes les classes de la société et
eon pour comprendre comment ça c'est
arrivé tu as besoin de savoir comment ça
a été internaliser en termes de mythe
chez les gens en terme d'histoire qui
ont un impact sur des sociétés et c'est
pour ça que de créer pour pour moi je
vois un enjeu à créer une histoire basée
sur la science est basée sur les valeurs
que la science promeut c'est à dire la
diversité le respect des opinions des
autres la collaboration ce que tu dirais
que c'est la science qui promeut ça ça
paraît bizarre qu'une phrase là
l'institutionnalisation de la science
par la recherche c'est à dire comment
est ce que la science et appliqués en
pratique elle promeut aussi certaines
valeurs que moi qui me paraissent bien
c'est à dire voilà ça toutes ces notions
de collaboration internationale de
savoir quand on met plusieurs personnes
de plaintes culture différente avec des
idées différentes est qu on l'est on les
fait parler et qu'on donne les moyens de
réaliser des trucs ensemble
eh ben on peut prendre des photos de du
début de l'univers on peut prendre on
peut découvrir le boson de higgs
on peut prendre la photo du premier trou
noir jamais réalisé mais pour ça on a
besoin de collaborer internationalement
on a besoin d'échanger des idées
librement et je pense que la science
elle promet aussi cette valeur lapin en
pratique elle est pas forcément
impliquer autant qu'on voudrait mais
dans l'image que je me fais de la
science et que des idées comme ça c'est
ça que j'ai envie de promouvoir
ouais mais ça met un peu mal à cette
idée de la science promeut des valeurs
ben pourquoi pas ce que parce que
la science a pris un peu ce débat en
fait entre prescriptif versus descriptif
qu'il a priori la science est là pour
décrire le monde montrent qu attend
beaucoup de discours je mets ça dans la
méthode scientifique science provins
valeur de non pas les siennes pour
pouvoir la méthode scientifique et un
peu décorrélé de comment est ce qu'on
fait à la science en pratique ouais et
je vois je vois là c'est la science la
science comme structure politique et la
science comme approche pour comprendre
le monde
je prouve que les deux les deux
approches on se sent corel ce corps elle
mêle c'est pas les mêmes quoi donc vrai
il faut les séparer
je suis d'accord par contre dans le côté
science en tant qu élément d'une société
en tant que production institutionnalisé
de connaissances sur le monde
on doit promouvoir des valeurs parce que
en fait on est des cons et des groupes
sociaux qui faisons des choses communes
et donc si on fait des choses communes
c'est qu'on a des valeurs communes
tu vois vl est-ce que c'est aussi le
discours en fait de donner de parler de
la science comme un agent quasiment
votre patience pense que tout est dit
que la mission guy promeut kiki choix un
langage qui qui me semble pas tout à
fait satisfaisant et bien c'est comme ça
parce que ça donne envie de dire la
science est avec moi ou la science et
céline est un peu de manipulation un peu
de temps la science
ouais bah ouais kike potentiel avec
beaucoup de gens font en pratique du
coup je vois je suis apte ans a pas
parlé de la science à part les amis de
la communauté scientifique on voit un
peu plus de qui on parle
obama ça me va comme distinction est un
pur coup on peut dire la communauté
scientifique à des valeurs parce qu'on
qui en pratique il se trouve que les
scientifiques ont tendance à être très
international monsieur votre être en
faveur de la collaboration
mais pour moi ça va au delà des
individus aussi un côté très systémique
de
il ya la production institutionnalisé de
connaissances qui offre un des
potentialités de collaboration qui
n'existerait pas juste avec
l'interaction des individus tu vois le
fait qu'on ait des colloques
internationaux on a besoin de financer
ces colloques internationaux on a besoin
de financer les voyages en évitant plein
de carbone de plein de chercheurs
différents dans les mêmes dans un
endroit en particulier pour essayer de
mélanger le tout pour essayer d'en faire
émerger des idées nouvelles mais ça ça
n'existerait pas juste avec la
collection de chaque individu quoi parce
que chaque individu à son projet de
recherche mais c'est aussi une manière
de s'assurer que la production de
connaissances soient accélérées c'est de
créer les conditions pour que certaines
idées se rencontrent à certains moments
tu vois ouais mais là encore je pense
qu'on peut parler de communauté
scientifique mais elle parlait de la
science sait on est d'accord sur la
distinction c'est trop monolithique et
ça me méritent d'être distingués ça je
suis d'accord
ouais c'est aussi des baux face aux
populations c'est un vote très connoté
moi j'ai beaucoup de prendre avec tous
les maux très connoté puis bien sûr ans
que tout le monde on vit les réutiliser
pour défendre leur propre la poésie des
toitures tendance à rester j'ai aussi ce
set recul avec une des idées comme j'ai
pas voilà les pays la france les états
unis
quand on dit la france a investi dans le
monde dont je parle dans les armes de
guerre ou la france la combattre thierry
on a cette vision un peu abstraite de ce
que c'est la france on a on a six villes
des valeurs on assimile des gens on
assimile des politiques mais des
structures et tout ça on met ça dans la
france ouais et en fait c'est ce
gloubiboulga d'idées là on
la tendance à construire une identité là
dessus alors que c'est peut-être pas
pertinent de considérer un pays comme la
source de ton identité
moi je me vois pas plus français que
therrien que j'ai du mal à voir ça
therrien c'est déjà plus fact fac based
parce que tu sais que tout le monde vit
sur une planète
cette planète c'est la terre donc c'est
plus c'est plus facile de ce qu'on
considérait comme terriens ou voilà
citoyens du monde mais c'est hélas assez
idéaliste qui parlait dé ce que je veux
dire c'est que je suis d'accord avec toi
que certains certains mots sont
tellement qu noter que c'est difficile
d'en déduire quelque chose de bien et de
pertinent sur le monde
j'ai déjà vers gré notamment rendre à la
marche les sciences ouais donc c'était
il ya en 2016 sans doute dit cette
époque peut-être un peu tous sommes en
année la grande allée est
du coup j'avais participé à une marche
ou des sciences et à genève et j'avais
été très malade très mal à l'aise tout
du long parce que les gens défendent ait
des positions politiques qui me sont
guiguitte qu eric et j'étais d'accord
mais ça me semblait très maladroite
d'associer ses valeurs à la marche des
sciences parce que la marine et son
envie de défendre surtout la validité
des sciences ouais en particulier sur
les questions de changement climatique
du coup parler de lui fait pas il
faudrait vacciner les enfants donc je
sais comme ça oui je suis d'accord mais
c'est pas un message scientifique c'est
biotine de ryu qui dit la science des
crimes mais n'est pas prescriptive pas
prescrits propos ne pas d'accord avec ça
sur le fait que la science avait juste
des frites iv pas prescrits
ouais je sais pas ça je sais pas quel
point ça se défend je le balance ça
comme une bombe mais laquelle
ouais parce qu'après c'est que débat sur
qu'est-ce que nation c'est tout ça peut
nous amener sur le troisième épisode du
podcast va durer cette fois eu tort mais
la méthode scientifique en tout cas tel
que tu as des crimes ne paraît pas fallu
c'est parce que peut-être une trompe en
disant mais ça ne me paraît pas il ya
laissé la place quel que soit le choix
de prescriptif je sais pas voilà non je
ne sais pas je pense pas mais bon je
sais pas quelle est la formule de belize
est purement prédictif et il faut un
axiome main droite les compare si on
veut transformer ça en quelque chose de
presque tiff
wen en jeu je suis d'accord avec toi du
coup d'autres choses donc fiable que tu
veux partager cette cage et au partage
et à whale et chose incroyable que j'ai
apprise en faisant par exemple de la
paléontologie zodiac
on est la dernière espèce d'humain qui
n'a existé sur la planète mais qui en
avait cinq ou six qui qui qui explorait
la terre il ya cent mille en quoi au
moins tôt 1,5 et des néandertaliens et
les hommes de flores
des mises au ban voilà et à un moment
dans notre histoire commune
on a interagi avec d'autres espèce
d'humain alors redéfinir espèce d'humain
sont pas faciles elles mêmes et on
vivait dans le monde du seigneur des
anneaux quoi il y avait tué des normes
et des hobbits sa fille avait des yeux
et des papas littéralement dans les gens
qui nous écoutent mais voilà c'est un
moment où on était avec d'autres espèces
consciente et on interagissaient avec
des choses qui étaient vraiment part des
choses des personnes qui étaient
d'autres choses que des humains et ça on
va oublier parce qu'on est les seuls
aujourd'hui qui sont aussi proches que
nous à être des êtres où on peut
échanger des idées on essaye avec
certaines espèces avec des dauphins ont
décerné avec des gorilles
on essaye avec des chimpanzés c'est plus
ou moins facile selon la structure de
leur cerveau et de leur organisation
sociale mer mais pour l'instant on est
on est tout seul quoi et alors les gens
qui se pose la question est ce qu'on est
seul dans l'univers évident réponse à ça
c'est qu'on l'a pas toujours été là et
je trouve cette idée géniale en fait bon
les a tous exterminés et probablement en
tout cas il s'est passé un truc dans
l'histoire qui a fait que toutes les
autres espèces sont son parti peut-être
dès qu'on la compétition de territoire
peut-être un changement climatique mal
géré peut-être voilà il tt génocide a
aussi une hypothèse mais on voit là on a
pas on n'a pas plus d'idées que ça pour
l'instant mais on n'a pas toujours été
seul dans l'univers quoi et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve dans une situation et
c'est là vous peut être rebondir sur des
trucs un peu plus actuel où on est en
train de
on est en train d'observer un déclin
massif de la biodiversité un peu un peu
partout on a 75 % de moins de vertébrés
qu'on en avait il ya 300 ans par exemple
je peux pas juste pour les mammifères on
à 60% hamas des mammifères c'est des
vaches et des cochons quoi genre 75 % de
la masse des oiseaux sur terre c'est des
volailles ces défis donc il reste plus
grand chose de sauvage de et spyeye
heine c'était des espèces qui partagent
notre voyage dans l'univers et et on est
en train de les voir disparaître peu à
peu et on a les moyens on a les moyens
de protéger ces espèces là parce qu'on
sait comment faire on a un consensus
scientifique sur qu'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment on n'est pas encore dans la
sixième extinction de masse comme
certains le disent parce que pour avoir
une sixième extinction de masse il
faudrait que 75% des toutes les espèces
qu'on connaisse disparaissent en un
temps très court
et pour l'instant on en est pas à 75
mais on y va à la clairement on est on
est clairement dans la bonne direction
pour y aller avec des gros sujets mais
mais on est sur le point de perdre une
richesse qui étaient là avant et qui est
toujours là aujourd'hui il reste des
choses à sauver qui est quand même ultra
intéressante
au-delà de l'aspect de l'aspect
complexité il ya des services
écosystémiques donc dont on a besoin
pour pouvoir faire fonctionner nos
sociétés que ce soit sur la gestion de
la météo sur la filtration de l'eau sur
les médicaments sur les trucs très
pragmatique mais aussi une valeur
esthétique incroyable dans la nature s'y
passe et a déjà vu des documentaires de
david attenborough le dernier avec notre
planète et ses fins et des images
fantastiques
mais ça on est sur le point de notre
impact est pas que positif
malheureusement notre impact a aussi
involontairement on est en train de
détruire cette richesse là et on est
dans une situation où on le voit cette
fois il ya cent mille ans tu demandes à
n'importe quel homo sapiens ce qu'est ce
qu'il va advenir de néandertal peut-être
qu'il avait une un point de vue très
tranchées sur ce que c'était un erreur
talent et à quel point ça fait pas
humain mais ben voila je aujourd'hui on
ne sait ça et on a une fenêtre d'action
qui est quand même assez réduite si on
veut sauver beaucoup de choses alors on
n'a pas de détruire la vie sur terre je
pense que la vie sur terre et se portera
très très bien pendant les millions
d'années à venir
mais la vie complexe la vie tel ou tel
problème bien avec nos chats nos vaches
avec voilà les lions les girafes tout ce
qu'on montre à nos enfants
j'espère que l'on pourra continuer à le
montrer à nos enfants arrière petits
enfants etc et à cette richesse là
j'aimerais qu'elle soit préservée
personnellement c'est très consensuel de
dire ça personne va dire que qu'il faut
qu'il faut détruire la nature va te vas
trouver quelqu'un qui va parler dans ton
podcast pour pour défendre cette idée là
c'est pas simple mais mais dans les
méthodes d'action
je pense que c'est de savoir ce que dit
la science à ce sujet d'être conscient
de ça et de du rôle que notre société a
avec un point de vue très factuelle quoi
avec des chiffres avec des sources
c'est important si on veut agir dessus
de manière la plus efficace possible de
savoir à quelle échelle de temps chaque
processus sur lesquels on agit agit de
savoir à quelle échelle on doit agir
est ce que c'est parce que c'est sur
notre agriculture est ce que c'est sur
nos l'expansion de nos villes
c'est pour ça un peu de tout ça a bien
sûr mais à quel point on devrait mettre
des sous dans tous ces trucs là ça c'est
assez à nous les citoyens de promouvoir
ce genre d'idée je pense à ce citoyen de
claire je pense que c'est là je pense
que les politiques sont pas forcément en
mesure de le faire pour l'instant parce
qu'il ya des barrières structurelles et
souvent des barrières idéologiques c'est
pas des gens le système électoral le
système politique qu'il est à l'heure
actuelle il n'est pas structurellement
fait pour répondre aux questions de
changement climatique d'érosion de la
biodiversité est en fait il ya des
blocages institutionnels à tous les
niveaux et il ya des gens qui étudient
ce genre de blocage ou est-ce que ou
est-ce que ça bloque dans l'est dans les
débats à l'onu ou des trucs comme ça il
ya des blocages qui sont maintenant bien
bien étudié et le fait que tu aies une
culture où ils étaient des citoyens une
collection citoyens assez assez immense
pas forcément tous les citoyens mais
bonne partie des citoyens qui prône une
certaine idée plutôt que d'autres ou qui
provient d'un certain constat plutôt
qu'un autre
sap à faire pression sur un système
politique pour changer le système déjà
quel que soit le système je suis pas là
pour promouvoir un système plutôt qu'un
autre
j'en sais rien en fait simplement je me
garderai bien de prononcer des discours
complètement politisé sûr sûr sûr ça
parce que j'en sais rien mais je sais
que si tu mets assez de gens tu peux
avoir un changement social et là où le
changement social peut arriver c'est
pour les villes parce que c'est là où
les idées assez diffuse plus facilement
c'est là où on peut réunir une masse
critique de gens pour faire des promos
voir certaines idées et puis pour
changer pour changer un système quoi il
parle il ya eu des moments dans le passé
où c'est arrivé je peux aller les droits
civiques pour pour les noirs le mariage
homosexuel
c'est s'aider des luttes littéralement
d'aider des luttes quoi c'est des gens
qui sont allés dans la rue qui ont promu
certaines vidéos jusqu'à ce que un jour
le système a changé et c'est une
conviction et bien sûr mais je pense que
il ya un potentiel encore pas trop
exploité à ce niveau là et que et que
c'est une manière d'action qui limite un
petit peu les inégalités donc qui répond
un peu à mes seins des penchants
idéologiques mais voilà je pense que
ouais faire sortir les gens dans la rue
sur sur le climat et promouvoir une
vision écologique et que l'écologiste
mme écologistes scientifiques qui n'est
pas un discours qui est très présent
aujourd'hui faut le dire parce que c'est
quelque chose que qui moi me frustre
énormément c'est beaucoup de beaucoup de
l'écologie politique aujourd'hui très
peu basé sur le consensus dans les
manières d'action dans les dans le rôle
de certaines actions plutôt que d'autres
je trouve qu'il ya énormément d'énergie
dans l'écologie politique qui est qui
est mal mal placé je crois qu'on en a
parlé dans le besoin de les podcasts
avec leur est d'ailleurs et on est assez
aligné sur cette question là mais voilà
quoi si ça me frustre comment est-ce
qu'on peut promouvoir une écologie qui
chante ific
alors ça c'est une grande question à
part on fait des bouquins fait des coups
ont fait on essaie de promouvoir sa dans
la culture populaire dans la rue dans la
qu'est ce que tu penses que votre
directement les écologistes non
scientifique ou puis ça je sais pas si
c'est très productif parce que finale tu
prends des écologistes et tu prends
d'autres écologistes et tu tues
fragmenter un mouvement qui dans tous
les cas là elle est fragmentée parce que
tous les milieux militants sont
fragmentés plus plutôt avance dans le
temps plus les mouvements militants sont
fragmentés et c'est normal parce que au
début tu es réunis sous la bannière
d'une grande idée et après cette grande
idée en pratique et elle se traduit par
plein de petites idées et tu peux être
en désaccord sur plein de petites idées
c'est génial parce que tu es partie d'un
mouvement qui était fort avec un grand
méchant et tout le monde va se réunir
autour du grand méchant et tu finis par
bata un mouvement qui va s'auto manger
lui même parce qu'ils se battent sur des
détails et c'est pas productif pour le
mouvement en général et je veux dire
je me garderai bien d'aller me battre
contre des gens des écologistes
politiques par exemple parce que c'est
pas je pense pas que ce soit raisonnable
de les combattre par contre d'essayer
dans ses mouvements de promouvoir de
promouvoir détruit par mois il ya une
association j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle avenir climatique qui essaient
de qui fait partie des acteurs de
l'écologie entre le milieu académique et
le milieu politique
les gens qui vont à des à des meetings
des discussions institutionnelles afin
qu'ils représentent des citoyens dans
des débats politiques
mais c'est aussi des gens qui vont
essayer de promouvoir une vision un peu
factuelle de ce que c'est les enjeux
énergétiques climatiques d'aujourd'hui
avec une validation scientifique
derrière et une liste de choses à faire
à plein de l'échelle différentes à
l'échelle de l'individu l'échelle d'une
société et je pense qu'ils ont sont sur
la bonne voie personnellement je
pourrais pas parler de tous les gens
dans ce truc là mais c'est un grand
moment ce je ne sais pas je sais pas à
quel point c'est un grand moi c'est un
mouvement surtout étudiantes et des
étudiants qui promeuvent de ces idées là
dans des milieux étudiant donc
donc ouais c'est généralement s'ils
organisent des comptes chaque année dans
toute la france où on nous forme à faire
une conf devant devant d'autres
étudiants et et c'est une espèce de
résumer du consensus scientifique
actuelle sur c'est quoi le constat et
comment on peut agir sur à partir de ce
que disent les scientifiques
donc je pense que c'est une bonne idée
mais c'est évidemment il n'ya pas la
bonne idée parce que ça n'existe pas on
vit dans un monde complexe et si j'avais
la bonne idée bas je l'appliquerais donc
mais c'est ça votre expérience que ça
extrêmement difficile en fait demain il
m'a demandé de communiquer autour de
l'écologie en particulier quand caen
pour y aider des personnes très vite
entre eux dix mois un terreau de faire
promouvoir des valeurs scientifiques au
sein de son mouvement aux hommes
d'expérience c'est pourquoi il ne fait
pas encore publiquement
je compte le faire quand je le serai
blindés sur sur la science en fait c'est
bon c'est aussi pour ça que je suis des
cours sur sur le système terre etc
c'est aussi pour la volonté politique de
changer un mouvement de l'intérieur ou
de créer un nouveau mouvement certaines
idées tu as forcément mouvement je suis
pas un lider de bourges ouvre en mai
mais voilà de promouvoir certaines idées
plutôt que d'autres
mais pour ça il faut être blindé
scientifiquement coiffe ou pas faut être
sûr de ce qu'on affirme si on veut
promouvoir ses idées parce que si on
hésite la manière dont on va le dire ça
va aussi impactés comment ces idées vont
être reçus après quoi donc c'est
beaucoup de réfléchir sur comment
comment promouvoir l'idée de manière
efficace
c'est beaucoup d'interagir avec plein de
public différent pour savoir qui sont
ces gens c'est on a facilement une image
idéalisée de certains publics
mais quand ton temps qu'on va pas
interagir avec les gens pour savoir ce
qu'ils pensent bas on est hors sol quoi
on sait pas on sait pas si on va dire là
ça va pas ça va pas agir sur certaines
sensibilités devenir négative et que les
gens vont se bloquer
de savoir où sont les blocages des gens
c'est intéressant pour si on veut
diffuser des idées quoi et c'est un
parterre de sonder un peu de comprendre
en fait pas ce qu'est ce qui motive les
gens avec les ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
va leur permettre de bien raisonné mt la
rue réplique pas les considérer comme
des conquois parce que c'est souvent cas
aussi dans l'est dans les milieux
militants c'est que tu considères
l'autre camp comme comme des pédophiles
mangeurs bon genre d'enfant
c'est typiquement ce qui se passe et il
ya énormément de d'énergie qui est
gaspillée dans des luttes dit lutte
entre opinions vraiment polariser sur
des idées qui au final si on se
concentrait sur les faits il y aurait
pas ces débats là et on a pas on a
besoin et des raies notre énergie sur un
truc comment ce truc commun c'est de
faire en sorte que on limite la
souffrance de de l'humanité et du vivant
du présent et du futur
donc ça si on peut se mettre d'accord
là-dessus déjà ça peut être pas mal non
t'es pas d'accord c'est pas toujours
facile de mettre ça en avant alors quand
tu reviens parce que passé le débat de
philosophie noircies d'accord je veux te
dire qu'il ya des trucs donc théologique
suivre rej assez bien je sers bien de
guérites de fautes non mais c'est ainsi
que c'est un des choses sur lesquelles
je réfléchis pas mal est notamment en
contact du développement international
alors j'ai pris pas mal de cours de
développement international et
généralement c'est les plans bonnes
intentions en mode on va voilà on va
réduire illettrisme dans certains pays
on va assurer l'éducation des jeunes
filles et je suis totalement alignée
avec ses valeurs mais ça dépend de
comment c'est fait aussi beaucoup
développement international qui s'est
fait en mode on est des européens où on
est des
la culture occidentale et on vient dans
votre pays et en vous vous apprend
comment faire de la démocratie on vous
apprend comment faire des trucs et s'est
pas fait avec une réflexion sur comment
est ce que les populations locales
voient le monde et parfois c'est des
trucs qui sont des gros échec quoi il ya
pas mal de podcasts comme 80 miller qui
part de ce genre de ce genre d' approche
la savoir si on veut qu'une approche
fonctionne si on veut améliorer l'état
d'un pays et les pays les plus
importants dans les dents les dans les
décennies à venir ça va être l'afrique
et l'asie enfin grand pays voilà enfin
c'est là où le boss phrase de rock lust
connaît rien au monde et donc
et donc voilà enfin en 2100 on s'attend
à ce que 80% des humanités ce soit des
africains les asiatiques
donc si on va voir l'impact le plus
global sur le monde c'est de passer de
se concentrer sur ces pays là par
exemple je sais pas comment serge eux et
je veux pas être interventionniste je
refuse de de faire de
l'interventionnisme dans des dans
certains pays par exemple je sais pas
comment je le ferai avec mes petits avec
mes petits bras mais
mais c'est pas une bonne approche et une
approche qui historiquement a prouvé son
inefficacité qui cotait
interventionnisme d'interventionnisme
c'est d'arriver avec sa culture de avec
ses valeurs et d'essayer d'imposer des
valeurs dans un autre pays avec à priori
interventionnisme c'est juste intervenir
non en fait il ya plusieurs manières
d'intervenir il ya intervenir en
discutant avec les populations locales
en sachant ce qu'ils ont besoin en
essayant d idées d aider de manière
structurelle et pas juste de leur
balancer des sacs de riz de savoir ce
que et juge important et souvent c'est
par ces approches là on fait que bâle et
certaines certaines populations se
développe ou pas il a une vision très
linéaire du développement de ce que
c'est le développement et et même dans
les sciences du développement c'est pas
quelque chose qui est consensuelle quoi
ça veut dire quoi un meilleur pays est
ce que ça va être un pays avec tous les
indicateurs de développement humain au
maximum est ce que ça veut dire
parce que c'étaient des indications
pertinentes les questions qui sont
fondamentales
et comme on ne vit dans une société un
peu globalisé sur plein de
plein de domaines pas tous les domaines
on a besoin de nos de répondre à ce
genre de questions parce qu'on va agir
sur sur les pays des uns des autres en
termes culturels en termes économiques
en termes politiques et de de savoir
comment chaque culture pense le monde
je pense que c'est un prérequis qui est
vraiment nécessaire quoi avant de faire
quoi que ce soit avant de faire quoi que
ce soit ouais parce que ça peut avoir
des impacts tellement négatif que ça
élimine tout ce que tu voulais faire on
n'est pas basse s'appelle agents
verbalisent et encore il ya quand même
les actions qui qui globalement on sait
que ça globalement et on peut y voir mon
havre de très bonnes raisons de croire
dont peuvent techniquement la solution
acheter les moustiques et après ces
trucs là s'il devient efficace acheter
des moustiquaires pour les pays en voie
de développement
sac à l'annulaire d'une intervention qui
est assez nettement bénéfique sur son
site et moustiquaires les populations
locales les considère pas comme quelque
chose d'important où tu vas jamais
diffusé des moustiquaires je veux dire
on parle des vaccins par exemple il ya
des gens qui on commence qui commence à
faire des vaccins contre ebola mais s'il
bosse pas avec avec les populations
locales pour promouvoir pas pour pour
dire que les vaccins c'est un truc
collet que si vous en avez s'il ya assez
d'entre vous qui en ont vous avez vous
peut-être de la chance depuis avoir
évolué si c'est pas interprétée comme
telle par les populations locales
elles vont pas se l'approprier et ça ne
va pas marcher et voilà a continué il ya
aussi des problèmes un peu clivante
garderai bien de faire des avis tranché
sur la question par exemple sur
l'excision
tu peux te dire que l'excision c'est une
torture par an tant qu'européens en
arrivant 10 et la torture c'est
intolérable
il faut pas faire ça quoi mais dans le
temps dans les pays où l'excision les
pratiques et c'est souvent des femmes
qui les pratique et qui promeuvent parce
que leur vision du monde est compatible
avec l'excision tu vois c'est ultra
difficile de prendre des décisions quand
tu arrives tu étais pas d l'onu et que
tu vois des choses comme ça il si tu
penses pas en amont a commencé les gens
voient demander comment tu le peux agir
avec eux pas sur eux avec bath ça rend
les actions difficiles mais plus
pertinent que je pense ben non je pense
que je pense que tu as pris des exemples
où en effet il ya la tension qui
apparaît mais pense qu'il ya pas mal de
cas où on peut être raison
parier sans trop flipper que si on
achète une moustiquaire accoutrement la
m et qu'on demande aux gens qu'on peut
devoir il faudrait pas je connais pas il
permet en ce domaine mais dans ce que
dit pas mal d'études est très efficace
et qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
extrêmement bénéfique à faire tout ça ou
par exemple acheter des médicaments qui
soignent des trucs de deux verbes qui
améliore grandement la santé mam et la
gaffe mais il ya la question de
distribuer le médicament et 2
et de quelle quelle est la fraction de
l'état extérieur qui va dédier des sous
à diffuser des médicaments dans les
populations locales
comment est-ce que ces populations
auxquelles vont intégrer ce médicament
et comment elles vont distribuer entre
eux c'est vachement difficile comme
question je veux dire c'est bon d'être
d'être testé de faire des apc quoi alors
certes il a été testé en l'occurrence
donc là il ya pas mal de données qui
montrent que pas part aux jeux un expert
de la question qu'on peut revenir aussi
sur les questions déposés contrôlés sur
laquelle j'ai une vidéo qui est sorti et
puis d'autres vidéos qui vous critiquent
un peu ça oui c'est critiquable c'est
quand même mais il fallait il y des
temps c'est que ces fendre les tests
qu'on veut mettre en place prennent du
temps des coucous coûte de l'argent à
faire mettre en place de la nation et
c'est du temps et de l'argent qui on va
pu être utilisé pour avoir des actions
qui sont soudain certitude qu'ils vont
peut-être marcher moins 90% du temps du
solent mais si ça marche 90% du temps et
que c'est un effet important c'est sûr
est génial c'est pas les seins
l'ignorance ne justifie pas une inaction
non mais bien sûr mais après tu prends
toujours le risque de tous trompés et
d'avoir une erreur qui va rêver sur sur
des générations pour moi je pense à un
exemple classique dans ce genre de cas
c'est l'histoire d'une ong je me
rappelle plus laquelle qui partit en
afrique pour pour construire des puits
d'à côté de certains villages pour que
l'accès à l'eau soit plus facile donc à
la base c'était les femmes qui est
jusqu'au jusqu'à la rivière locale pour
prendre de l'eau et pour ramener dans
les villages et cette ong et deux mois
plus tard elle est revenue et elle a vu
que tout le tout leur pluie avait été
avait été cassée volontairement par les
femmes parce qu'ils n'avaient pas pris
en compte que bah en fait c'est des
sociétés vachement patriarcale et ac est
la seule manière d'émancipation des
femmes qui avaient sûr sûr sûr dans le
coin c'était 2 à c'était d'aller
chercher de l'eau c'était la seule fois
où il s'est retrouvé entre elles où
elles pouvaient échanger des idées et
ferrat et le mg et terriers avec ses
gros sabots déconstruit sont cuits en
disant voilà ça c'est le besoin des gens
locaux ils ont besoin d'eau mais sap a
été pris d'une manière intégrée et en
restant en interagissant avec les gens
je vais que ba leur action ils ont mis
beaucoup de moyens et ça va pas marcher
ou quoi ouais t'as eu le même impact
pire parce que si tu t'en empêcher un
lien social qui était à la base de cette
société aqua du vote du coup il ça pose
la question de vraiment de du suivi des
ong de
vérifier que leurs interactions sûrement
bien sachez d'apparence mais met tous à
se faire parce que c'est déjà en place
en jeu des pacsés par en place un jeu
dit que c'est des méthodes à promouvoir
quoi ces méthodes pour moi mais c'est ce
que fait beaucoup la halle très efficace
propos bon ça je fais plutôt je pense
que je suis plutôt aligner là dessus
après et si on a du coup quand tu vois
les plus le futur de l'humanité
principaux ce qui l' écoute les
principaux risques du futur de nos
possibilités maca cas d'échec la mort du
soleil sera encore un bon rythme pour
dominer par an à l'échelle de quelques
sites du siècle on peut aller à quelques
siècles et si tu veux aller là bas pour
moi les les publient plus grande menace
pratiquement cessé aussi le biais de la
littérature j'ai lu à ce sujet c'est
notre atout d'un parc notre impact sur
l'environnement
donc le changement climatique qui peut
déjà dit si à l'échelle de 1100 porter
la planète à 5,6 degrés maximum pas plus
un mais cinq six degrés c'est ce qui
sépare un âge de sierre de la journée
aujourd'hui et est donc voilà pour moi
une des plus grosse menace pour
l'humanité c'est le changement
climatique et l'érosion de la
biodiversité
donc c'est des problèmes qui sont liés
en fait parce que l'érosion de la
biodiversité est aussi dû aux
changements climatiques pacc eux il y
avait cinq facteurs qui sont qui sont
mis en avant pour l'érosion de la
biodiversité et à la destruction des
habitats la pollution l'introduction
d'espèces invasives et le changement
climatique
et puis le l'exploiteur sur la
surexploitation des espèces aussi et
voilà
et voilà donc c'est ça c'est les deux
trucs qui m'ont qui m'inquiète le plus
haut sans cesse manifesterez comme pour
paul junot pour les humains en fait
introduit des pressions supplémentaires
pour les stabilité de nos sociétés je
veux dire genre la fertilité des sols ou
la pollinisation des plantes elles sont
assurées par une biodiversité qui si
elle disparaît va mettre à mal la
fondation de nos sociétés c'est à dire
l'agriculture genre une grande partie de
ce qu'on a dans nos étalages de
supermarché c'est des trucs qui ont été
colonisés par par des abeilles etc
mais si tapie d'abeilles pour les
coloniser site à plus de l'insecte
pollinisateur battu tu as pu tous et
toutes ces cultures la cie tapis de sol
qui sont fertiles
parce que ils ont été arrêtés et rodez
par des générations de
soit des pesticides ou wan et des
méthodes pas soutenable d'agriculture
d'agriculture intensive
bah tu t'exposes à ne plus pouvoir
produire à des famines sur sur le long
terme et les famines c'est pas bien pour
la stabilité d'une civilisation général
voire d'une société le mot civilisation
est un peu connoté donc société donc ça
c'est l'érosion de la bio
la biodiversité produit pas mal de
services
on appelle des services écosystémiques
qui sont ultra bénéfique pour pour pas
pour notre vie à nous et puis pour pour
la vie de tout le monde quoi le fait
d'avoir des écosystèmes stable c'est une
bonne idée si tu as envie de rester en
vie de quoi alors tout ce qui est dit
filtration l'autre ce qui dit réduction
des températures captation du co2 dans
l'atmosphère
voilà il ya énormément de choses qu'on
ne voit pas forcément mais qu' on est
deux on n'est pas une société qui hors
sol qui qui dépend de rien quoi on n'est
pas juste là avec notre pétrole et
nôtres béton à faire des trucs on
utilise des ressources de
l'environnement et ses ressources
certaines sont pas renouvelables
il y en a plein conte etc on surexploite
au delà de ce que la nature peut
régénérer et on le fait à une vitesse
qui est quand même assez inquiétante qui
est qui une vitesse qui est plus
importante que la vitesse à laquelle on
les comprend et et ça s'est passé pas la
définition de la sagesse quoi ça serait
bien qu'on comprenne notre impact avant
d'agir seulement sur des trucs mais je
trouve que notre société annonce trop
vite pour que pour qu'on puisse faire
quoi que ce soit pour pour comprendre
les choses
avant qu'elle disparaisse quoi donc ça
n'inquiète pas mal ouais c'est
l'agriculteur finalement le mouël a
grillé sur l'agent général faire juste
les terres qu'on dédie à l'agriculture
c'est 30 37 % des surfaces non glacée de
la terre sont recouvertes par par des
terres agricoles quoi il appela les
trois quarts de ces terres agricoles
sont utilisés pour des pour du bétail
donc sauf que ce soit pour nourrir le
bétail ou pour le faire pâturer enfin
pour le faire bouger
et ça c'est inquiétant quand même c'est
une grande fraction de la surface non
classés de la terre si tu sais de la
terre qui n'est pas utilisé pour capter
du co2 par exemple et ça c'est une un
des éléments majeurs de notre impact sur
la planète c'est ce à quoi ces
agricultures non seulement le co2 qu'on
aimait dans l'atmosphère mais c'est
aussi le méthane que nos vaches et
cochons balance dans l'atmosphère le
méthane qui a un pouvoir de
réchauffement de 2 20 fois à celui du
co2 méthane s'est pas bien quoi on
n'aime pas le métal et il ya plein
d'éléments qui peuvent être surprenants
parce qu'on comprend pas encore le
système terre très très bien enfin on
comprend certains trucs on peut dire des
choses avec un degré de certitude assez
élevé mais il ya aussi des choses on ne
prévoit pas par exemple l'un des trucs
typique qu'on dit dans l'est dans les
sciences de l'environnement c'est le
permafrost le permafrost et c'est toute
la surface des sols gelés sur la planète
qui contiennent énormément de méthane et
le métal voilà c'est un gaz à effet de
serre ultra
dutra violent et si la planète se
réchauffe
à tel point que les surfaces gelé des
jeunes ça va ajouter une énorme quantité
de méthane dans l'atmosphère et on a des
voiles à des phénomènes qu'on voudrait
pas quoi on va pas qu'on veut pas que la
planète se réchauffe d'un coup comme ça
parce que ça met des pressions sur les
environnements beaucoup plus élevé que
ce qu'on a à l'heure actuelle
et là on a des risques vraiment sérieux
sur la stabilité des civilisations des
sociétés après est-ce que le changement
climatique l'érosion de la biodiversité
cd risque existentiel c'est à dire est
ce qu'elle met notre espèce l'existence
de votre espèce en jeu je ne sais pas
montré de nos sociétés en jeu carrément
et et je voudrais pas être la personne
qui ait raison dans ce genre de truc en
disant que l'humanité peut être atteinte
si vous bougez pas maintenant vous voilà
tu restera qu'à l'échelle belge et un
nom à notre siècle en fait je pense que
le problème c'est qu'on n'agit si on
agit sur la sur le système terre à une
échelle qui se content siècle alors que
la plupart des événements qui ont eu
lieu dans l'histoire de la terre se joue
sur plutôt sur des centaines de milliers
d'années sur des millions d'années
histoire de laisser aller
nature le temps de se régénérer quad de
s'adapter à des changements de
l'environnement parce que je trouve que
voilà la terre c'est plutôt résiliente
comme comme système elle supporte la vie
depuis maintenant 4 milliards d'années
on est dans une dans une planète qui
gère pas mal les choses en terme de
garder la vie vivante
quelle que soit la ville d extraction
masse dans le passé il y en a eu cinq
dans l'est dans les 500 derniers
millions d'années mais mais on est dans
dans une période de temps on est dans
l'inconnu quoi ces terrains connus tard
c'est pas on sait pas comment va réagir
le système terre avec une perturbation
qui est aussi rapide et aussi brusque et
ce serait bien qu'on comprenne les
choses avant de avant d'avoir cet impact
là mais c'est pas le cas donc sa main
qui a toi donc le changement climatique
et la perte de biodiversité inquiète
plus que joueur la dispersion des
ressources naturelles pour moi je vois
ça comme un ouais c'est aussi par les
ressources naturelles c'est surtout en
particulier ouais alors ça c'est enfin à
partir du moment où il ya d'autres
sources d'énergie disponibles qui
peuvent être renouvelable solaire
l'éolien etc
même le nucléaire a plu lire cette
flamme mais c'est plus qu'honorable que
enfin c'est pas renouveler la maison qui
est une échelle de temps beaucoup plus
élevé pour le nucléaire et s'est
jusqu'ici commissaire en effet le temps
pour le nucléaire parce que nous sommes
excités
non mais il n'y a pas beaucoup d'uranium
dans l'est dans les sols mais enfin
c'est des trucs qui viennent du centre
de la terre et qui sont qui sont qui
sont mis à la surface par par démonter
d'orange confusion mère je n'ai pas les
chiffres
je vais pas je vais pas m'avancer mais
par contre voilà l'épuisement des
ressources fossiles on sait que ça
s'épuise donc ça on le sait depuis les
années 70 un moment qu'on sait on sait
qu'on va continuer à en extraire parce
que notre société c'est un peu leur noir
enfin le sens de notre société et vous
c'est un prénom à mon grand désarroi
mais s'il ya une inertie dans système
qui fait qu'il ya tellement d'intérêts
économiques pour le faire et notre
société elle est tellement basé là
dessus qu'on va continuer à le faire et
ce sera de plus en plus difficile et ce
sera de plus en plus cher et à
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrive sur des
énergies renouvelables et qu'on investit
dans la recherche surtout de de manière
plus efficace de produire de l'énergie
parce que pour l'instant c'est comme des
thématiques qui sont sous financés à mon
goût
donc au delà du fait qu'il faut
promouvoir les renouvelables mais
d'améliorer les renouvelables existants
c'est quand même pas mal
rien que le solaire on a des rendements
qui se comptent en dizaines de pourcents
fins et 10 15 % au maximum un panneau
solaire aujourd'hui 20 pour les
meilleurs et à part d' exploiter toutes
les ressources qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle un terme aux intellectuels et
en termes move économique pour faire de
la recherche dans ces trucs là c'est du
high risk highgate quoi on peut bien par
mois je prendrai des trucs comme ça par
exemple parce que financier largement
cette recherche
ouais ouais il ya une espèce de
l'urgence de trouver des sources
d'énergie qui soit non seulement plus
efficace en termes de captation
l'énergie mais aussi qu'ils soient pas
cher parce qu'il ya aussi une
implémentation à prendre en compte et et
qui aurait il y aurait peu de frais au
remplacement recyclage ouais ça ça ça me
pue stockage et le stockage ouais il ya
un gros enjeu sur le stockage totale aux
charges pas si on parle de recherche du
coup au niveau de la culture pense pas
qu'il y ait eu pas mal de recherches à
faire sur con je pense que le droit de
l'agriculture alors oui il ya des
recherches en affaire notamment sur le
fond c'est que les monocultures par
exemple c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas qui fait pas sens du terme
d'écosystèmes en fait la nature elle
fonctionne pas comme ça et le fait de
d'avoir des monocultures sur des
hectares d'une seule plante c'est pas
bon pour pour les sols c'est pas bon
pour plein de choses et donc pendant la
majeure partie de l'histoire de
l'humanité on a eu la sagesse de deux
fameux sagesse antique de soin de
laisser des forêts repoussé avant de
pouvoir avant de faire de l'agriculture
dessus soit de faire des des rotations
de cultures en prenant des des plantes
riches en azote genre des légumineuses
des poids et ses pourboires et enrichir
les sols en azote pour pouvoir faire de
l' agriculture soutenable bas depuis
qu'on devait qu'on sait produire de la
zot en masse depuis l'atmosphère donc c
est l inventions les plus
révolutionnaires du 20e siècle le fameux
procédé à leur gauche tu prends du dia
zone de l'atmosphère
tu converti en ammoniac et on fait des
engrais azotés et à ça ça te permet de
voila tu balances et en masse sur un
seul et ça te permet de faire des
monocultures en masse même et ça nous a
pas eu que des fins a permis à la moitié
de l'humanité de manger aujourd'hui
celles qui mangent de manger mais ça lui
aussi un impact négatif sur sur les sols
sur comment est-ce que par les seules
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui pour
l'agriculture on pourra peut-être peut
les utiliser plus tard donc ça ça me
vois ça ça m'inquiète un peu
après je ne suis pas spécialiste du
sujet donc je pourrai pas aller beaucoup
plus loin sur ces sur ces questions là
mais de ce que j'ai lu c'était ça le
gros risque quoi ok mais a priori parce
que enfin ils enfin plus de recherches
dans cette direction ouais carrément
carrément bas en agroforesterie des
trucs enfin il ya déjà des choses qui
seront kouame mais de prendre ça et de
les mettre à plus grande échelle
ça me semble pertinent comme approche
mais il ya aussi une approche très
politique de ça c'est pas moi qui veux
le dire mais c'est de la majeure partie
des scientifiques qui voit sur le sujet
de limiter la consommation de viande
la consommation de produits carnés en
général et de favoriser une alimentation
végétale c'est pas juste un délire de
vegan c'est aussi des problèmes très
très pragmatique sur comment est-ce que
tu gères tes sol comment tu gères des
émissions de co2 et de méthane et ça
c'est quelque chose que je pense
importance s'il y avait moins de vaches
- de cochon
on s'est dérobé des paix partout on
aurait moins de co2 et de ses de ch4
dans l'atmosphère ça c'est des
problématiques très très pratique quoi
et pour qu'on consomme moins de viande
il faut un changement culturel il ya des
blocages culturels et dans certains pays
c'est plus difficile que d'autres en
chine c'est un un symbole de haute
statue de faire de au statut de manger
de la viande donc et une consommation de
viande qui augmente dans ces pays là et
on peut pas leur en glaner non plus
parce que on a fait ça pendant un moment
aussi nous mêmes et mais voilà on c'est
factuel c'est factuel que si on on
réduit la surface de la terre dédiée à
l'agriculture combat des foires et à la
place on a moins de pression sur
l'environnement et on n'a peut-être plus
de temps d'agir sur d'autres trucs donc
ça ça me semble pertinent comme approche
au delà de la recherche juste part de
l'action citoyenne et de haut niveau des
institutions des politiques et c'est de
changement culturel en général et quads
approche
pourquoi est ce qu'on mange de la viande
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on a besoin de
manger autant de viande pas faire des
trucs prescriptif de si vous mangez de
la jambe je bouge je veux dire moi je
suis flexitariens je mange
j'en mange aussi de temps en temps
j'essaie j'essaie de réduire au maximum
mon quota de viande les gars un conte
social aussi aujourd'hui de se dire
végétarien parce que dans selon les
endroits où tu es tu vas pas forcément
être traitée la réunion donc à la
réunion c'est une alimentation très très
basé sûr sûr sûr la viande donc quand
j'arrive chez mamie et que je suis
végétarien ça passe pas vraiment et je
peux pas leur en blâmer c'est culturel
et donc donc quand je vais chez ma
famille je mange de la viande
enfin je leur ai exposé mes idées
d'abord et après si ça passe pas je
mange de la viande parce que j'ai pas
envie de passer des milliers d'années à
débattre d'un truc qu'on sera jamais
d'accord mais aurait des milliers de
litres inquiète à l'esclavagé serre et
donc voilà je pense que c'est une
approche aussi intéressante que la
recherche quoi mais du coup quand
promouvoir ces changements de culture
ban en occupant un espace médiatique en
occupant un prog en bas vrai encore une
fois c'est parce que ouais j'ai une
vidéo qui lui est ressorti sur ce sujet
qui sera sans doute déjà sorti avant
impliqué sur ce cas surtout kg en deux
épisodes
est ce que monsieur mba va donc bon au
pire je couvre assis ici si la surface
moment la sortie mois sur le thème la
vidéo fait donc sa série à tema tant
mieux et tita vidéo ce sera a pris vers
tous bien plus tactique c'est pourquoi
je suis devenu végétarien et des jambes
et je pense au lycée c'est sûr je
réponds à cette question pour nous
vraiment mais pendant déjà c'est que
comme toi en fait
les situations où manger de 40 g de
viande est assez coûteux socialement et
du coup je suis excité rien également
mais pendant longtemps je dis que je
suis végétarien prendre le menu
végétarien en tout cas et cécile sont la
première fois que j'ai fait c'était
difficile de rester devant tapez
psychologiquement difficile qu est ce
qui m'a fait devenir et à la raison par
lequel ces déficits c'est parce que
aussi parce que j'associe beaucoup le
végétarianisme par sig et plus encore le
véganisme à des discours très virulent
ouais mais il ya aussi il ya aussi un
homme de paille à ce niveau là c'est à
dire que ce qu'on entend le plus des
milieux militants ont végal s'est massé
l214 c'est des trucs où ils vont faire
des actions très parents très très
voyantes et quand tu es un mouvement
social et qui essaie de promouvoir
certaines idées tu es obligé d'aller
dans du fringe parfois pour attirer
l'attention du public
ouais les films et des abattoirs de
données regarder des actions barbouillé
de sang pour parler devant des
boucheries des actions qui vont une
symbolique mais qui ont quelque chose
qui sont aussi extrêmement violente
quand tu es un public qui n'est pas
qu'ils aient pas exposés à ce genre de
questions quoi je peux comprendre que ça
peut bloquer certaines personnes mais du
coup à tout ça pour moi en fait en tout
cas pouvoir c était contreproductif
c'est vrai que ces cdt des raisons pour
ne pas devenir végétarienne essais mais
je pense que ça bloque plein de gens
parce que l'image les vegan qu'on a
aujourd'hui
voilà le le bové guen qui mangent du
quinoa et qui va protester devant les
abattoirs mais la pince évidemment que
c'est un cliché enfin c'est pas c'est
pas le cas de tout le monde et il ya peu
de gens qui vont un peu de jambes je
sais pas mais je pense qu'une approche
efficace pour promouvoir
végétarianisme véganisme dans une
société c'est pas le mou c'est pas le
discours moralisateur de il faut pas que
vous fassiez ça parce que dans le il
faut pas il ya plein de choses qui sont
cachés et tout le monde n'a pas la même
capacité d'action selon le milieu social
dans lequel il d'arriver en mode hero
morale en disant un l'âge je sais ce qui
est mieux pour tout le monde et même ce
même si tu sais ce qui est mieux pour
tout le monde ça va pas forcément passer
si tu dis tu devrais pas faire ça
voilà c'est quelque chose très difficile
à faire passer mais je pense qu'on y
arrive avec des incitations bah je sais
pas moi des incitations économiques des
incitations toujours dit et incentive
quoi et puis parfois de lacq et le
comportement du maire pour pouvoir de
mettre des options là où il y en avait
pas avant de promouvoir certains menus
plutôt que d'autres voilà ça peut être
des milliers d'actions qui peuvent être
intéressantes quoi mais qui dépasse le
côté individuel puisque être un individu
c'est dur parce qu'on est dans une
société et c'est la société qui dirige
un petit peu les décisions des individus
et des sociétés en partie mais mais on
est dans des couloirs dans des couloirs
sociaux et il ya pierre bourrelly les
est con qu'on agit souvent de la manière
la moins coûteuses socialement donc on
va demander dans les chemins de moindre
difficulté et on a raison le faire parce
que c'est dur de faire des actions qui
vont à l'encontre de ce que tout le
monde se dit autour de toi et sois tu es
un héros moral et que tu décides d'être
sur un autre plan d'existence que les
autres soit essaie de changer de
l'intérieur ton groupe social et où nous
te mettre avec des gens qui sont qui ont
ces valeurs là parce que c'est beaucoup
plus facile quand tu as des amis j'étais
à rien d'être végétarien en général mais
moi je sais que dans mes propres choix
il ya eu un un des collègues afin d un
des grands amis dans mon ancien labos
qui quittent et vegan et donc et qui
contraste est vraiment l'image du végal
tel qu'il était avec l'image que j'en
avais moi c'est à dire cet activiste
très virulent et c'est donc lui c'était
carrément l' inverse alors c'est un
activiste mais ces deux là personne n'a
plus le plus génial que je connais c'est
que la plus gentille quoi ea et ça a
joué énormément sur le fait qu'un jour
je me suis dit je vais tenter aux trois
semaines de véganisme et je les fais et
je vais demander conseil à cette année
il m'a dit qu'est ce que lui faisait et
comment est-ce que et pour la première
fois de ma vie j'ai réfléchi à ce que je
mange avec moi j'avais jamais fait avant
et j'ai trouvé ça très stimulant
intellectuellement quoi delà de
l'expérience bas de savoir pourquoi on
mange qu'on mange qu'est ce qu'on mange
c'est important quand même je crois que
je vais te citer dans ma vidéo parce que
j'ai pas encore film est presque au go
c'est exactement le discours passe à dix
et que j'avais prévu d'avoir fait ça
parce que j'ai des amis qui a et évitera
une particule commencé et qu'ils
n'étaient pas chiant par rapport à sa
colas et si c'est plus facile d'accepter
parce que les arguments ils sont
convaincants à la nation les arguments
écologiques les arguments bas après les
arguments moraux ça que ça convainc pas
tout le monde va dire la souffrance
animale c'est pas quelque chose soit
quelque chose qui compte en tout le
monde j'avais l'impression fâché
l'impression que ça va ça court ben les
fautes pour contexte qu'il faut mois
peut-être c'est parce que sinon c'est
fascinant de la saucisse à quelque chose
de virulents brethous année c'est très
difficile de ton tant d argent est dans
une position de défense déjà du coup
assez la fameuse rect logis voilà on te
présente un modèle un nouveau modèle du
monde et comme tu a forgé son identité
sur sur autre chose te balance à la
gueule cette nouvelle vision du monde de
manière pas très subtil et forcément tu
te rends tu te repli sur tes valeurs et
sur sur ton identité et
et bien c'est un mécanisme humain il
faut le comprendre il faut savoir bien
tourné si tu venais faisait ton idée là
ce que du coup tu parlais au début de
prendre le paysage médiatique
c'est quelque chose il faut que ce soit
bien fait qu il ya vraiment un risque
que ce soit de mal fait je sais bien je
sais bien mais en tant qu en tant
qu'individu ou de collection d'individus
c'est difficile de faire autrement il ya
déjà des canaux d'information qui
irriguent notre population soit les
canaux officiels style bfmtv lci
ces animaux etc soit il ya plein de gens
qui font je dirais tu prends aurélien
barrau qui promeut une vision écologiste
du monde et qui donc est parfois un peu
virulent mais qui essaie de rester dans
du factuel la plupart du temps ray après
avec certaines dérives de temps en temps
mais il joue aussi sur les sur le
comment le média fonctionne pour attirer
l'attention et ça ira les choses de très
réfléchi derrière je repense à un moment
où il veut j'avais d'un moine de vue de
ces vidéos
une vidéo où il apparaissait en tout cas
où il parlait de moi je frappais il
paraît directement du véganisme si je me
trompe pas oui et on vous disait que
c'était prouvé scientifiquement que
c'était bien pour la santé
ouais et ça s'est passé j'ai déjà fais
pas trop les études sur lesquelles ils
s'appuient mais un jeu souvent le j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui on a arrêté d'être
vegas que pour des raisons de santé
donc oui bien sûr bah après il ya la
notion même de la vitamine b12 est
d'être un complément des compléments
conte à prendre si on est des gannes
merde avait apparemment selon les
lorsque j'ai lu à ce sujet je suis pas
du tout aux experts vont je vais pas
m'étendre beaucoup là dessus
mr une alimentation basée sur les
plantes a tendance à être beaucoup
un dangereuse aucune alimentation
essentiellement basée sur la viande
notamment pour des raisons de maladie
cardiovasculaire qui est le plus gros
l'un des plus gros tueur dans les pays
développés elle est différente parce que
la tuque ou parce qu'ils mangent que les
gan versus you je suis là viennent il va
bien pour l'alimentation vegan
apparemment un projet d amis médecins
qui évidemment promeuvent une
alimentation mixte avec un peu de viande
avec un peu de diversité dans
l'alimentation
mais dans ce qui concerne le véganisme
il ya pour moi y ait de ce que j'ai lu
j'ai pu en discuter j'avais des
colloques végal chez moi pendant pendant
un moment
il répartit d'être inefficace qui les
gens bien et si qui me disait que ça
parlait les compléments en b12 ya pas
grand chose en termes de pertes père
contrit sionnel qu'on a en tant que
vegan quoi je suis à vitry sioniste je
fais pas être là dessus je le fais que
répéter ce que j'apprends mais je pense
que c'est un sujet suffisamment
compliqué mais pour ne pas ce point pour
ne pas pouvoir se permettre de dire on
va être vegan et bien pour l'as moi je
le prendrais pas comme ça par exemple je
donnerai pas le faire comme ça parce que
ma déjà j'ai pas lu les études et que tu
vois là quoi c'est pas mon rôle il
faudra vraiment des études soit parce
que c'est ce qui est contre hector
profusion noms et les associations c'est
compliqué ça je suis d'accord que c'est
un mauvais argument si on voit le
promouvoir le véganisme ya des bons
arguments pour promouvoir véganisme mais
c'est pas de forcément cela j'aurais
tendance à être très vigilants sur les
mauvais argument fut intense à dire car
un mauvais argument porte à cause et 1
et contre tacos je suis complètement
d'accord
je suis complètement d'accord c'est
quelque chose qui minent énormément de
déjà de l'écologie politique
et ouais c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais j'aimerais pas mal changé si
si si tu peux essayer de promouvoir des
idées tu as forcément la tentation de
vouloir de vouloir utiliser tous les
tops les armatas disposition parce que
les gens ils sont ce qu'ils sont et ils
vont réagir delà d'une manière qui est
parfois prédictive prédictible véritable
lecture plutôt et d'autres non va et
visible au litre ou d'anglais et me
voilà enfin si si tu as toujours cette
tentation de vouloir utiliser toutes les
armes à ta disposition
mais il ya des dérives à ça et la dérive
majoritaire c'est que tu mine tout
mouvement de l'intérieur ouais
et puis même de x-ore parce que si
quelqu'un veut critiquer le véganisme
oui absolument
je suis l'homme de paille avec ça et ça
ne risque pas d'opa donc cesser c'est
pas facile mais j'aime ce genre est ce
que j'ai quand même l'impression que
voir le végétarianisme se diffuse petit
à petit c'est l'impression que j'ai
aussi mais après c'est difficile de me
dire avec une grève c'est compliqué de
dire sans études mais j'ai l'impression
que voilà presque peut-être nos
communautés mais et du coup enfin parmi
les gens que je connais ça marche
vraiment beaucoup plus par phénomène par
contagion mais ça serait ce que dix ans
dans n'importe quelle idée tu tu donnes
pour promouvoir une certaine idée il
faut une masse critique jusqu'à et une
institutionnalisation de certains
politiciens belges par contagion
bienveillante que c'est très belles
affaires à travers cette année ce qui
peut bien marcher way pour le
végétarisme vieillissement en
particulier donc nous on va essayer tout
ça par rapport à d'autres préoccupations
souvent soulevée par un profiteur du
réalité par exemple augmentation des
inégalités
quand tu places à habas j'ai vu pas mal
de deux bouts de bouquins un sujet sur
les lieux robert la lettre classique
jarrett d'iam
donc voilà tous ces gens qui ont étudié
d'un point de vue j'ai pas envi
ronnement talent des points de vue
social d'un point de vue politique
historique
pourquoi est ce que les sociétés
s'effondre et un facteur qui revient
souvent c'est les inégalités sociales et
ouais enfin je pense qu'il faut se
battre pour une société plus égalitaire
c'est pour des manières au delà du côté
moral ça c'est mieux que tout le monde
ait les mêmes chances il ya un côté très
stabilité de nos sociétés qui est aussi
qui peut être aussi important parce
qu'on vit dans une société le côté moral
tout le monde daté gosses que je pense
que c'est un truc qui quand il suffit
pas mal les gens iront voir monsieur
fixe les affaires sont ceux sont doute
en tout cas par rapport à ça le côté
égalitaire bon ben ça se discute d'un
point de vue moral
tous mes deux potes c'est très
pragmatique de stabilisation c'est
s'arrêter c'est vraiment quand même un
point d'orgue
ouais c'est limiter les inégalités
sociales culturelles dû limiter les tout
parti quand un rapport de pouvoir entre
des classes les plus hautes et les
classes les plus basses et beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop élevé et on a une
augmentation des inégalités qui est en
place depuis quelques quelques décennies
ça des trucs qui sont qui sont mesurées
quoi ouais c'est assez inquiétant si du
coin mais ça va avec le reste toutes et
tous ces problèmes qui minent la
stabilité des sociétés en général ils
sont généralement liés et c'est ça qui
est super chiant c'est que si tu
augmentes les pressions de
l'environnement due au réchauffement
climatique taux augmente le risque
d'illégalité parce que c'est des pauvres
qui vont toujours cracher pour les
autres et est donc une mine la stabilité
de la société parce que ballet des gens
qui ont qui mangent pas à leur faim ils
sont pas contents et les gens qui sont
pas contents c'est des gens qui peuvent
renverser la société mais voilà j'ai
j'aurais tendance à promouvoir ce genre
ce genre de discours plutôt que faire de
l'égalité un objectif une obligation
morale
bref le sait pas parce que encore qu'on
dit ça c'est promouvoir l'égalité
en fait c'est pas tellement les pauvres
qu'il faut convaincre c'est plus les
riches comme un certaine manière et les
riches ils verront beaucoup plus si on
leur dit que c'est une question de
stabilité de la société et qu'il ya des
risques en fait surtout pour eux un papa
que pour eux déçu aussi et pour eux ce
sera un message beaucoup plus
convaincant pour eux que toujours
intense à dire ne parlait de sa culture
ouais ça les dinos ne pense que ces
actes là dessus
les raisons des raisons d'être altruisme
des raisons égoïstes des tracts oui
c'est ça et dérivant des raisons
égoïstes de talent triste et moi et moi
je suis moi ce que j'ai fait qu'à ce par
pur égoïsme
je supporte modifications mais je ne
sais pas comment comment ils vont voir
le mieux à dire si tu prends dans
l'histoire des mouvements sociaux
il ya eu plein de choses qui ont
fonctionné c'est vrai que tu peux
contribuer lancé scullion dire avec le
fait que le message égalitariste on va
dire et on a tendance à mieux fédérer
martin luther king tu prends au nelson
mandela
je prends tout toutes ces figures qui
sont aujourd'hui des dépôts starchild
des mouvements sociaux gandhi etc
c'est des gens qui promouvait ces idées
là pour des raisons morales quoi et ils
ont réussi pour ça osias plus facile de
fédérer autour de ça que fédérer autour
de du risque de défendre au nom de la
société à cause de tensions
géopolitiques
oui oui moi ç'a déjà que c'est plus
difficile à comprendre mais du coup
c'est peut-être intéressant d'adapter
son discours au cas par cas et puis
aussi d'être bon peut-être un petit peu
plus peut-être pédagogique par rapport à
tout savoir moi vraiment où tous ces
enjeux parce que il ce qu'il ya des
mouvements égalitariste qui me semble un
peu comme
il fera trop virulent que kiki riches
qui voient ça il se dit je pense que ça
va au delà des caractéristiques c'est
juste dans les mouvements sociaux en
général à partir du moment où tu deviens
trop extrêmes tu vas être mal perçu par
une certaine fraction de la population
et tu va agir à l'encontre de tes
valeurs où à l'encontre de ce que tu
défends des hauts des bas et ça c'est
l'extrémisme c'est pas bien pour une
raison très pragmatique que ça marche
pas plus que ça alors ça marche dans
certains cas je prends tu prends le
terrorisme ça marche plutôt bien pour
diffuser certaines idées dans la société
mais mais après hotels le retour de
bâton que bâton terrorisme je lis tu l'a
promu d'ailleurs tout à fait peur à des
milliards de personnes c'est vachement
cool
félicitations m mais maintenant tout le
monde va être bombardé la gueule et au
final quand il existera plus bas des
idées elle meurt avec toi j'aurais
tendance à dire on peut en particulier
sur des points qui sont complexes où il
faut vraiment le temps problèmes
environnementaux
même les égalité sociale ccco fremm en
fait vraiment complexe winkler ça paraît
à répondre à ce genre de problématique
je pense à on n'a pas les on n'a pas les
structures qui nous permette de
réfléchir à ça sur plan des chefs de
temps pour pour répondre à tous les uns
des enjeux que ça du coup utiliser des
arguments pour fédérer avant tout qui
qui risquent en plus de faire des trains
peut lire le nom ça me semble assez
néfaste pour la réflexion autour de ces
sujets non mais tu peux pas tout
maximiser ainsi si tu veut maximiser la
portée de ton message en termes de
nombre de personnes
tu vas être obligé de
deux lycées ton message par exemple ou
alors rêve tu vois il est toujours des
compromis à faire mais qu'elle
réfléchisse suffisamment au compromis à
faire alors il faut être dans les
moments militants pour savoir mais même
vouloir des mouvements militants donc
par exemple des trucs de jijé tu t'es ça
aujourd'hui je n'ai toujours pas bien lu
les réponses parce que je pense que je
vais faire très critiqué mais donc
donc il ya le conseil fed qui défend le
mauvais au pâtis et amir intuit il ya
quelques jours sur qui rejetait en gros
les expériences contrairement à leers et
l expérience en domise est contrôlé en
double aveugle et énormément du coup de
sceptiques devant du mouvement aux et
éthique qui ont qui ont faire henri
tweet commenté de ça avec beaucoup de
virulence et beaucoup de moqueries
beaucoup de sarcasme des critiques que
j'ai sur le mouvement sur les mouvements
et éthique et rationaliste dont je fais
partie donc je suis de l'intérieur je
pense pouvoir le dire mais la manière la
plus bienveillante possible certaines
approches sont contre-productives et de
ne mérite pas enfin vous valez mieux que
ce à quoi les âges enfin je sais pas moi
je vois énormément dans les communautés
et éthiques des gens qui passent leurs
journées sur facebook à m
dd même sur à quel point les gentils
vague se sont cons à quel point leurs
enfants vont mourir à quel point les
plates east a lassé des débiles mais
mais si ça sert à quoi enfin je veux
dire comment tu commences tu promeut ton
idée comme ça quoi
déjà tu vas convaincre que les
convaincus et en plus tu va générer une
espèce dépolarisation artificielle que
tu as créé ouais et tu peux plus
discuter avec les autres parachutistes
qui s'est créé un mur tout seul je
jouais en quoi jouer études comme ça
défile et de loin qui du couteau tourner
en dérision de
le truc est dit mais si je connais pas
le mot et éthiques c'est ça j'ai pas
envie qu'on sait c'est même pire que
j'ai pas envie c'est que j'ai envie de
les critiquer quand je les vois une
nation dans ce cas je pense que c'est
pour ça que l'asiatique a une mauvaise
image dans certaine fraction de la
population qui parce que bat pour ces
raisons là ne pas parce que il ya de la
violence il ya de la malveillance mal
placé et c'est dommage
sa coupe un dialogue qui aurait pu être
mieux ouais hein dis pas qu'il faut
parler avec tout le monde mais c'est
quand même mieux de d'ouvrir un d'ouvrir
un pont plutôt que de mettre une
barrière
ouais c'est bon je me suis fait critiqué
pour avoir par les mauvaises personnes
c'est foutu ça fait mal et du coup ça va
être au sujet de la polarisation est ce
que c'est un truc qui te préoccupe la
polarisation ouais ouais ouais voilà le
tout le côté batou côté bulle de filtrer
tout ça c'est quelque chose qui me
manquait un petit peu enfin je sais à
quel point ça m'inquiète parce que c'est
vraiment des pour le coup là c'est des
effets indirects
quand tu prends le réchauffement
climatique ou l'érosion de la
biodiversité tu peut tracer la chaîne de
causalité pour arriver à commandant
société s effondre à partir de ces
pressions qu'on met ou master system
dans ce qui est bulle de filtrer
polarisation des
des avis dans les sociétés et comment
les idées elles seront échangées et
comment elles sont échangées contre des
gens qui sont d'accord de plus en plus
et comment les algorithmes et aide avec
sa basse et plus l'impact il est plus
indirecte donc c'est plus difficile de
prédire
est-ce que ça va encore plus direct plus
bas je ne sais pas surtout parce que
j'ai pas lu la littérature à ce sujet tu
vois faire par exemple pour être élu un
nouveau géant jaune ça correspond une
bulle fins d'aider les gens sur facebook
qui qui qui se suivaient pas mal comme
moi et puis il ya en effet c'est
concrètes pour le coup est donc donc on
peut imaginer que les trucs soit encore
plus accentuée dans le futur et qui
dirait qu'ils ont de plus en plus
polarisé et qu'ils sont convaincus d'un
truc parce qu'ils sont entourés de gens
qui sont convaincus du même truc
ouais et voilà le monde quoi ça me
savais faire d'anti les mouvements anti
vaccin donc sceptique mais je suis
d'accord grossir et qui peut avoir des
conséquences politiques apprécient aussi
bon c'est ça oui alors pour répondre à
des missions oui ça m'inquiète je sais
pas dans l'échelle de 1 ha ha je ne sais
pas répond s'inquiète mais sa main qui a
trait en particulier aux états unis où
des sanctions de démocrates républicains
et démocrates ont tendance à penser que
les républicains sont des idiots
et inversement et inversement d'ailleurs
certaines certaine il est alors j'avais
lu des articles de sciences de la
communication des sciences qui disait
que généralement quand tu te forge une
opinion sur sur un sujet scientifique
genre le changement climatique pour le
cool les études portaient sur le
changement climatique disait que les
gens qui aux états unis qui qui était
climato sceptiques
il y avait une énorme colonne
corrélation avec leur identité politique
et qu'il s'était beaucoup plus corelec
l'ignorance scientifiques qu'ils avaient
donc tv certains républicains s'étaient
surtout associé au mouvement républicain
que les républicains qui avaient
énormément pour inquiéter les considérer
comme les plus lettrées scientifiquement
et est aussi ultra climato-sceptiques
quoi que c'est des gens qui associent
leur identité politique à n'importe quoi
et ils vont voir le monde par le prisme
de leur identité génétique et c'est
dangereux mais c'est humain
donc on à même de comprendre c'est bien
pourquoi ai je pas si c'est vrai il faut
pour des raisons que vous réjouir de ce
qu'il faut comprendre et vous qu'est ce
qui peut être fait on va revenir au
levier de loire qu'est ce qui peut être
fait alors petit que non je sais pas ce
qui peut être fait
autant je passe énormément de temps à
réfléchir à ces questions mais je suis
aussi un vase clos et enfin je cherche
aussi des gens qui pensent un peu comme
moi ça c'est un appel bouteille à la mer
du méric
je cherche des gens qui réfléchissent à
ses idées à et qui ont une approche
rigoureuse et rationnelle des choses
pour pour se fédérer et promouvoir ses
idées là
les idées dont on discute depuis
maintenant elle est très efficace les
menaces majeures un truisme efficace je
sais pas quel point y est
j'aurais tendance à dire oui sur
quelques sujets dont sur sur d'autres et
résister réussi c'est quoi tes points de
désaccord avec la très efficace
j'avais peur de cette question parce que
j'ai pas révisé j'ai arrêté de réfléchir
altruisme efficace depuis 1 depuis un
moment car je suis passé à autre chose
ce qui distingue history et tout ça ce
qui fait mais mais ouais je sais que ce
que j'aime bien dans la prochaine
truisme efficace c'est le côté approche
rationnelle de privatisation de cause ce
que je n'aime pas voilà ce que j'aime
pas assez le le côté on va limiter notre
mouvement à une classe sociale
particulière et je comprends les raisons
qui qui peuvent laisser penser ça mais
sociologiquement les gens qui promeuvent
la triste efficace viennent d'un certain
milieu ça ça se voit sa sentence à celui
et c'est un milieu qui ce qu'ils se
parlent entre entre entre lui-même quoi
et je trouve que ça limite vachement la
diversité des discours qu'on peut qu'on
pourrait avoir dans ce genre de
mouvements date rythme efficace et je
pense que ce mouvement ce qui est cool
avec ce mouvement c'est qu'ils s'auto
corrige qui essaient de deux d'avoir ce
côté réflexif pour essayer de devenir un
meilleur mouvement mais il ya ce mois là
disons que si t'es pas utilitariste de
niveau 7 le niveau c est en tout cas
c'est difficile de se considérer que le
triste efficace aujourd'hui et puisque
tu es très il ya ce côté city tu promets
une cause qui ne mérite pas ce côté très
utilitaire 7 x 2
tu dois mettre ta vie un peu
moralisateur tu dois mettre ta vie au
service de réduire tous nos réalisateurs
en fait c'est bon j'ai eu énormément de
débat avec eux soit avec mes colocs avec
les gens avec qui j'ai interagit et
l'altruisme efficace et souvent très mal
perçues pour ça pour son côté non
seulement élitiste mais aussi pour le
côté moralisateur de j'ai eu des échos
demain de gens qui se sont faits jugés
par dan altruiste efficace parce qu'il
faisait des carrières qui n'étaient pas
assez efficace
par exemple la drôlesse on est sur des
problèmes individuels c'est pas
forcément moment même et quand on voit
ce genre de moi j'appelle ça des dérives
quand on voit ce genre de dérives et les
impacts psychologiques que ça peut avoir
sur certaines personnes qui voudraient
s'engager dans quelque chose pour rendre
le monde meilleur
bah ouais il ya des critiques et a
apporté à ce niveau là je serais
d'accord
[Musique]
or pour que les élitistes
oui clairement de la très efficace et
très élitiste pour des raisons que je
trouve plutôt bonne mais du coup mais
qui sont discutables ou parce qu'en fait
c'est pour avoir des bons débat est allé
assez loin dans la réflexion utile à
voir quand même pas mal de balles mais
un mouvement un mouvement social face à
des syndicats c'est un mouvement social
pour pourquoi avoir un mouvement social
efficace n'a pas besoin de ces taudis
des tas besoin de gens qui répondent à
cette idée et a besoin d'eux
voilà elle mais tu étais un peu toujours
ce compromis entre la vitesse avec elle
tu preuve pour diffuser les idées et la
qualité de l'information qui a largement
torture qu'un truc entière de manière
très efficace avoir misé sur la qualité
d'information puisque la quantité
oui je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est face
à des problèmes qui sont vraiment
complexe qui nécessite vraiment de la
qualité d'information beaucoup plus que
de la quantité
peut-être mais je sais pas si c'est
suffisant bah dis donc c'est là sur quoi
d'être efficace mais c'est que la
quantité il y en a beaucoup des ja et du
coup on ne recrute pas beaucoup en se
mettant sur le cheval de bataille de la
quantité
ouais par contre la qualité à me sens
extrêmement déficiente aujourd'hui très
peu de de contenu par exemple sur la
formule de paysans par hasard par hasard
ça du coup je pense que c'est important
d'avoir beaucoup plus de quitter ses
intrigues par un peu aujourd'hui mes
vidéos font beaucoup moins d'un point de
vue qu'avant et je trouve ça fait pire
enfin c'est ouais c'est bien ça me
soulagent un petit peu un mois que mon
impression l'impression mais aussi je
sais que du coup je parle plus à des
pour un passionné ou des gens qui sont
vraiment prêts à prendre le temps de la
réflexion et je pense que ça permet
d'aller plus loin
réflexion donc ce soir notre devenir
élitiste j'étais folle que
bon oui billet de blog était forte
baisse du coût et isme je comprends mais
je pense que c'est justifié
et puis l'autre portant que juger les
autres moralement s'il ya déjà très
efficace qui force à bâle je me désole
largement je les juge pas vraiment c'est
je pense qu'ils veulent bien faire mais
c'est à dire est que les gens si elles
font parce qu'on est d'accord sur le
fait que c'est pas souhaitable faut
vraiment essayer d'être attention mais
absolument pas juger les gens et puis
donner aux vivres plutôt que voilà il ya
eu aussi une une autre critique que
pourrait que je pourrai attentes et
c'est le gros focus sur sur les
individus et sur voilà ce que tu peux
faire sur ta carrière ce que tu peux
faire avec ton argent ton truc tango aux
teintes avis tonton d'un drap etc tu
limite un impact qui pourrait être
beaucoup plus fort si tu réfléchis c'est
en terme social en terme de groupe
mais ces scellés au premier commencé
voilà bien sûr je comprends merde mais
vous limitez sciemment votre impact
comme ça sans que tu parlais que je
parle maintenant de la très efficace
mais que tu as dit bout en fait je suis
aligné à moitié sur tellement de trucs
rdc lisible je ne sais pas à quel point
je me comment je me sens face à la
triste inefficace aujourd'hui notamment
parce que je ne réfléchis pas énormément
non plus à votre niveau sur voilà sur un
supposé cordes ou alors ils veulent en
mai quand je dis vous je parle au micro
et aux actrices mais j'ai jasé reste
stable à l'entente de la têt
sa mère mais ouais je suis content que
ce soit un mouvement qui soit
autocritique et mais j'ai aussi des
critiques a apporté quoi mais je ne sais
pas il faut en discuter
je sais pas à quel point j'ai de
l'énergie pour discuter toute ma vie sur
c'est sur ces sujets là aussi deux
priorités qui sont pas forcément la
lignée avec les priorités de la truite
efficace notamment parce que prioritiser
des causes je suis moins difficile et
c'est bien de faire cette démarche en
pratique
mais à partir du moment où tu fixe une
liste de dire stop 1 ceux-ci top de ce
site au coude droit s'était un peu
obligé une serre de manière matteo banon
mais je suis d'accord que terry
contrainte mais mais tu sais tu obliges
à négliger certains trucs lors dé ce
qu'on appelle les sites des signaux
faibles quoi qui situe négligeait pas
ça aurais tu pourrais mieux agir sur sur
le monde quoi et pour le coup ça j'ai
l'impression que c'est un truc à elle
très efficace fait très très bien d'être
sensibles à des signaux faibles moyens
beaucoup mieux que n'importe quelle
autre
moi ce que parce que j'avais comme comme
critique alors ça c'est souvent un point
de dissension avec moi et ils font
d'anciens collègues c'est c'est le
statut du changement climatique wesley
qui n'est pas mis dans des priorités par
les attriste efficace pour la raison que
c'est pas un problème qui négligeaient
mais je pense que c'est un problème qui
est négligée parce qu'on n'a pas la
proche la bonne approche pour le faire
pour pour le résoudre on met beaucoup de
moyens dans des approches qui n'ont que
peu d'impact
du coup ma part je pense que le problème
n'a cessé il faut cesser trop vaste
français au changement climatique
oui il faut cibler un peu plus quels
aspects en particulier quelle action en
particulier
ouais mais donc par exemple c'est
difficile parce que le changement
climatique c'est un problème intégré et
un aspect qui me semblent négliger c'est
la qualité d'information autour de
changement climatique ouais et donc donc
si tu vends ça d'accord je pense que
pour une priorité importante et c'est
une qualité de la qualité d'information
il ex la pédagogie autour de tous les
problèmes réfléchir globalement à
caissons une meilleure stratégie
quels sont les leviers d'action
oh oui je pense que c'était des
considérations qui très efficace en
effet attendre c'est un peu négligé ça
et je pense que c'est un problème c'est
une critique jamais très bon allez les
petits signaux faibles ça c'est un truc
au bar tribe linky et hauteur de ceux
qui gèrent le podcast et issa harouna
wars qui rendait des gros trucs de la
tribune efficace il parle souvent en
fait quand même de deux temps par
rapport à tout ce qui est au risque
ouais il parle beaucoup de de devoir
s'aventurer deux ans que de donc je suis
il ya un épisode où il parle des trains
je suis moi ces inventeurs capitalisme
start-up heure de là le très efficace du
co cc a essayé d'identifier des
problèmes qui ont peu de chances d'être
un vrai problème mais qui pourrait être
vraiment un gros problème
on est qui ont été négligés du coup et
c'est de faire une recherche
préliminaire sur ça et je pense qu'en
effet c'est un truc important à faire
c'est d'identifier huit angles morts et
non pas par typiquement récemment
malheureusement à chaque fois que je me
pose des questions je retrouve
potentiellement à des tribus font
flipper ça va ça c'est les ordinateurs
quantiques c'est un truc ça fait flipper
les ordinateurs quantiques passe même si
si si et des ordinateurs quantiques à 4
min 8 go 5008 l on va faire mal tous les
systèmes de cryptographie aujourd'hui
peuvent être à quai et ses fils ont été
lancés ces ultras suivant je comprends
pas la fin mais il a oublié aussi des
gens qui réfléchissent à comment faire
de la crypto de la cryptographie
quantique
ouais mais c'est pas dit qu'à très tôt
daifi quantique arrivera avant la
cryptographie quantique est toujours
ambitieux s'est pas dites suis surtout
c'est pas dit que les entreprises
implémenteront on la cryptographie
quantique une fois que l'ordinateur
quantique or atteint 4000 que huit voies
et moyens pratiques mais même s'il y
avait une crypto quantique et conseils
tu disais c'est à dire que tout ce qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui sera déchiffrable
d'ici là super donc tenable et messages
tout mon historique de porno il sera
découvert s'il sera découvert par celui
qui veut lancer un calcul sur nortel là
là tu m'as fait peur tous les
extracteurs et des fichiers sexe et puis
si on va parler dans le premier ou le
dernier épisode
j'ai voulu parler d'eux pour la paire
ailleurs la mise pour les auditeurs sur
le premier épisode je pense voilà enfin
dans une situation de plus mais je pense
que c'est ce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de manque de réflexion autour
des vrais pros 20 de tous les problèmes
négliger braquo de gens qui pensent aux
problèmes n'ont négligé
huawei a little dream est mort alors je
suis complètement d'accord avec la
platitude que toulouse b voyez quand
même besoin de plus aux gens qui
réfléchissent à des trucs qui qui qui
tous ces problèmes qui sont
potentiellement des bijoux ouais et du
coup je pense que c'est une des
préoccupations par rapport au changement
climatique des actrices efficace et que
ans devant trop d'attention à ce
problème en particulier on néglige tous
ces autres problèmes
moi je comprends l'argument je moi ok
donc segmenter le changement climatique
en plusieurs sous problème
alors ça c'est peut-être une proposition
[Musique]
faite le m c'est ce qui est coûteux
parce qu'il ya est un peu un amalgame
sur pas mal de questions
environnementales que je trouve assez
assez noir problématique mondiale un
amalgame
dans la sphère écolo on va dire me tente
entre beaucoup de problèmes qui me
semble très différents sites et
nucléaires et les ogm on savait cette
enveloppe se faire des ennemis tout de
suite mais même au sein de d'aider les
gens qui font qu'ils s'intéressent à
elle à l'écologie de façon scientifique
il échoue que c'est dommage de mettre
trop de choses dans le même panier et
d'avoir une discussion un peu plus fines
autour de certains aspects en
particulier c'est un peu ma critique
envers les écolos scientifique réfléchir
aussi peu plus à au levier d'action
ouais ouais ouais levier d'action ce
serait bien s'il ya des gens qui sont
spécialistes dans les changements de
société qui nous écoutent pas qu'ils
veulent promouvoir ce genre d'idée on
sait jamais ce qu'il a parce que du coup
ça m'avait amené du coup
vidéo que j'ai fait qui s'appelle la
solution honte aux changements
climatiques sont bons titres ultra put
aller cliquer oui je comprends tu avais
vu cette vidéo je sais plus donc il
parle de youtube
oui l'idée donc ça serait de modifier
l'ia de youtube dont la rendre bénéfique
pour l'humanité typiquement en
promouvant des vidéos qui prône un fort
esprit critique dans mon vis-à-vis des
médias qui fasse réfléchir et jean et
qui met en avant en particulier
cet homme parle depuis trop longtemps
ok donc promouvoir davantage des vidéos
qui sont de grande qualité enfin
nationale typiquement et qui soulignent
davantage les enjeux importants pour le
futur d'humanité ouais alors plutôt que
les idéaux stationnement clients comme
comme comme opinion je sais pas comment
je me sens avec avec cette idée là je la
trouve intéressant qu'en fait ce qu est
la première personne que j'ai entendu
qu'ils ont qui parlent de cette solution
là mais c'est vraiment un point parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya peu de
gens qui réfléchissent à bombay un livre
que je me sentirai doit s'assumer en
fait c'est tellement à place mais c'est
c'est tellement associé aux questions de
censure
et de voilà de liberté d'expression etc
ces deux thèmes qui sont tellement
centraux dans nos sociétés actuelles que
tu vas toucher à ça tu te situes tu
t'exposes un énorme bâclage quoi c'est
même même si ton idée elle est justifiée
je sais pas si elle ne le prononce pas
une opinion sur ton idée en pratique
mais sur la manière dont elle va
interpréter ça peut être ça peut ouais
ça peut vachement te rendre impopulaire
au niveau global
je pense que j'ai du coup pas très bien
fait cette vidéo s'il devait refaire
aujourd'hui je donnais pendant que les
conférences pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui
sur sur ce sujet vraiment rentrer les ja
bénéfique en particulier système de
recommandations et je pense que je n'ai
pas très bien d'année mais ouais il ya
j'excuse mes bêtises de c'est un peu ça
fait la gloire des erreurs mais j'ai
fait une erreur je pense quand même la
vidéo est globalement bénéfique du coup
j'ai quand même laissé j'ai pas j'avais
hésité au walhalla aux tirs et 1 mais je
pense que la vidéo a quand même
globalement bénéfique qui ceci dit si je
devais le refaire je peux y crée très
différent mais ça fait partie des
erreurs au printemps par contre je
parlais de la morale les ja j'ai arrêté
de faire ça je commence quand je parle
de rendre les îles bénéfique parce que
je pense que c'est mon plus grand ça
c'est même message mais ça ça passe
mieux ouais ouais j'ai déjà progresse
donc aujourd'hui la manière dont je
prends souvent le sujet c'est plus de
dire que nancy c'est d'abord sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui cia de recommandations
elles ont un objectif en tête ouais
maximiser auditorium commune les gens
vont passer sur ces plateformes que cet
objectif il est tel qu'il est et voyez
pas d'autres en tout cas et il a des
effets secondaires des effets
secondaires très indésirable c'est à
dire que c'était l'objectif et
l'objectif est vraiment très bien
atteints par cette ia
mais enfin dans cet objectif elle
augmente je pas la polarisation le
partage des vidéos énervez pas mal
d'effets secondaires
les bills aux conspirationnistes et tout
ça est que il ya un potentiel énorme
fête à rendre sesia bénéfique à plus à
changer à cette fonction d'objectifs et
à au moins a rajouté dans cette fonction
objectif d des considérations sur lequel
il ya un peu un processus souvent ouais
mais après tout les expose à des à des
effets non auquel tu t'attends pas en
jeu mais il faut du coup une vocation à
se dire fuck you when you tube c'est
aussi un système complexe et donc tu
sais pas comment ça va être interprété à
ce genre de par les gens qui vont qui
vont consommer des vidéos sur youtube
tu vois tu peux pas imaginer un
changement culturel alors j'imagine un
tel scénario dystopique je sais pas à
quel point il est il est plausible ou
des vidéos qui sont promus par youtube
sont les vidéos du consensus
scientifique et qui représente certaines
idées plutôt que d'autres les gens vont
le savoir
ça va créer un scandale monstres et les
gens vont arrêter de regarder les vidéos
sur youtube parce qu'ils savent que ça
va être associé aux gouvernements et aux
institutions
et comme tu as déjà une défiance envers
les institutions des institutions
politiques parfois pour des très bonnes
raisons et aux scientifiques parfois par
de très mauvaises raisons de très bonnes
raisons parfois aussi tu peux est exposé
à une espèce de rejet massif de tous
contenus la barre si c'est vraiment mon
scénario dystopique je ne sais pas à
quel point je fais un homme de paille en
disant ça mais c'est une conséquence que
je juge au moins plausible quoi alors
carrément le truc c'est que s'il y avait
conçu
mal conçu fin et qu'elle prend pas ça en
compte
bah il va y avoir beaucoup de
conséquences potentielles donc c'est
vraiment enfin la destruction et c'est
le cas du insiste beaucoup peut-être que
j'aurais dû ainsi c'est directement
cette vidéo mais en fait sa vidéo juste
après sur les quatre vingt six fois ce
que cette vidéo sur fnatic
en fait c'est vraiment une introduction
la vidéo prespes suivante et ballon
c'est ballot et bâle et moi plus
tactique a su inventer et lille avignon
c'est vraiment insisté sur le fait que
c'est un point extrêmement difficile de
rendre désir bénéfique boston parle de
plus parce qu'on me parle d'un défi
digne des ternes en mathématiques de la
prochaine génération
[Musique]
quelques mares pour défendre un peu
sévère et hectares doit appeler ça le
plus grand défi l'humanité moi je pense
vraiment que c'est vraiment le truc le
plus important aujourd'hui rendre les ja
bénéfique et c'est ultra difficile il
suffit pas de dire laisser vraiment
ultra difficile et a besoin en ce sens
d'un si on massive dans le recherche
pour faire ça surtout de manière robuste
parce que comme tu l'as dit à youtube
c'est un environnement complexe avec des
agents papa gentil gentil qui sont
surtout là pour leur propre but
où voir juste pour [ __ ] la merde et du
coup dans ses rangs on parle
d'environnement guess by antho mon
engagement d'informatique désolé pour
les bisontins
[Rires]
en fait c'était choisi exprès main forte
pour ces raisons droit et c'est un
problème extrêmement difficile mais par
contre il va falloir un fort besoin
parce que les îles youtube postes déjà
énormément de problèmes
et si on fait rien ces problèmes ne
seront pas résolus comme par exemple la
fonction des antilles vers des vidéos
montées vaccin qui touche les îles par
leur préparant au pire moment où ils
sont plus dans le doute
c'est ça tue des gens place mais voilà
ces défis c'est difficile alors je
prendrai pas position sur ces sur ce
sujet là en particulier parce que c'est
un sujet qui est tellement complexe je
me refuse de tout rejeter en bloc tu
vois c'est pas c'était pas ma
personnalité
et puis tu refuge en bloc de toujours
juste et dollar exactement je sais pas à
quelle porte et ça aurait 7
elle a porté sur mondial pour le coup
c'est des milliards de personnes c'est
vraiment un bon ajustement de est ce que
cette porte est très positive ou
négative tu vois et à quelle échelle sur
quelles échelles de temps sur les
impacts directs et indirects ça aurait
après la question si super en termes
d'action c'est toujours positif ou
négatif par rapport à un seuil de
référence et surveillance
aujourd'hui c'est maximiser tant
qu'elles ont passées sur youtube ouais
bien sûr mais ça paraît difficile de
faire moins bien que ça c'est le serbe
qui a forcément un gain la visite à sa
limite certains trucs aussi généreux
maxim's et walsh times ça promet certes
certaines certaines vidéos mais pas la
plupart des vidéos qui sont provenus sur
youtube cette vidéo bénigne quoi c'est
des gens qui vont manger des mns de
manière sexy c'est des gens qui vont
revenir dans des choses et des gens qui
vont se badigeonner de vomi
on tremble aux autres je savais jouer
avec ça on vient de découvrir
l'historique de sueur bref c'est la
vidéo qui suit beaucoup vu mais la
plupart des vidéos à 18 millions d'euros
un milliard de vues c'est des trucs
comme quang nam style françois aussi
aller sur youtube de pub dise en quoi
non mais voilà c'est la plupart du temps
c'est des vidéos qu'ils ont qui ont un
impact sur la culture sur la société
bénin quoi ces pays si bien que ça c'est
difficile à évaluer quoi de l'impact
direct lors du bonheur des allemands en
particulier je sais pas mais voilà des
médias des vidéos de musique second ont
une influence sur sa der sar n'est pas
au delà de l'aspect il ya l'aspect
écouter des musiques sur youtube youtube
c'est la très majoritaire sur pour l'
écoute de la musique mais youtube ne
permet pas sauf si tu souscrire youtube
prévient d'éteindre ton écran et en fait
il ya eu un impact
il ya des études qui ont montré qu'un
impact écologique incroyable injuste
parce que youtube est là et la
plateforme majoritaire pour la musique
et je trouve ça fou enfin c'est un acte
qui pourrait tellement simple à faire
mais qui n'est pas fait par youtube et
donc à la fin tu pourrais imaginer que
youtube même en maximisant soit stein
décide de laisser les gens et éteindre
leur écran pour écouter des podcasts ou
des idées de la musique coule ou quand
même stand mais ne le font pas mais ça
c'est typiquement un levier qui me qui
me sont vraiment partout et à considérer
est donc pas pareil je pense que pas mal
des vidéos je crois que tu dis pas ils
font ces tumeurs donc je cite sont pas
elles influencent beaucoup de choses de
la culture a été courue tube heures
français la vraie fâché oui par exemple
c'est cette histoire j'ai trop folle de
l'ama fâché c'est des gens qui qui qui
semblait agir en toute impunité même si
même s'ils font des choses en toute
illégalité
et c'est qui que ce soit d'ailleurs je
ne sais pas qui c'est mais dc ouais
c'est assez fou de se dire qu'ils sont
au delà de ils ont tellement à intégrer
le système et ils font tellement marche
le système qui sont au-delà des lois
généralement et puis enfin est ce
qu'aujourd'hui à 70% des vidéos des vues
sur youtube qui ont des résultats de
vidéos recommandé par l'union donc les
gens qui s'impliquent énormément dessus
notre stade ces folles c'est il ya plus
de vues sur youtube que de recherche sur
google pour whaou
oui qu'est la dumas my blood depuis 2016
ya de youtube avoir une influence russe
comme c'est fou il ya deux
recommandations et il s'agit pas de fait
quand même pas besoin de censurer et
juste besoin de moins recommandées par
exemple masculine mais qu'ils peuvent
ils seront recommandés hygiène mentale
mais tu peux imaginer que c'est une
forme de censure ou que ça peut être
perçu comme une forme de censure par
certaines personnes s'affairent ça
qu'ils présenteraient vocale mais j'ai
envie de dire mes vidéos sons sont pas
suffisamment recommandé parler de
youtube moins qu'avant ça ne dérange pas
par contre ce qui me disent que je
trouve vraiment bien c'est que j'ai le
mental face 10 millions de vues plutôt
que 100 me de ca monde est d'accord on
est tous les deux des fans des
événements tels il suffit de changer il
ya du tube pour que ce soit bon c'est
pas un truc énorme suffit de
bah ouais mais à partir du moment où tu
influe sur autre chose que des
métadonnées que tu as un futur vraiment
le contenu de ce que les gens vont dire
il ya un côté moral qui était dans la
zone grise quoi tu sait qui est qui qui
est l'instance qui va déterminer quels
contenus raide mais si tu vois là ce
serait il y adeux youtube après ouais
mais qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une entreprise youtube genre
peut-être tu serais prêt à ce qu'on fait
déjà je veux bien mais on serait prêt à
donner le pouvoir à youtube
alors c'est pas comme si on avait le
choix mais avoir le choix à youtube de
de dire ça c'est une vidéo légitime
ça c'est une vidéo - légitime donc j'ai
moi la recommander ce pouvoir-là faceo
watch de watchmen quoi ses voeux on soit
a besoin d'une instance de régulation
qui est transnational et qui va
déterminer qu est ce qu est ce qu ils
pas ceux qui passent pas et là je suis
déjà plus serein 6 sur le genre
d'implémentation mais c'est pas du tout
le genre d'implémentation là on parle
d'une entreprise qui a les pleins
pouvoirs sur ce qu'elle va diffuser et
qui peut avoir un impact monstrueux
selon ans selon ce qu'elle va promouvoir
ou pas c'est déjà le cas c'est déjà ça
mais là tu lui donne encore plus de
pouvoir sur ce qui est la norme reste
quelques connaissances et légitime pas
bien total plus de pouvoirs à la
délation pouvoir non parce que la l1
fait pas directement sur le contenu
l'âge influe passion tout s'est passé si
tu dis hein c'était contenu peut être
plus recommandés parce qu'il est plus en
accord avec le consensus scientifique
donc pour ça il faut savoir de quel
contenu on parle pas de varier déjà une
analyse du contenu automatique ne fait
pas rire
li a fait du sous titrage automatique et
bien sûr en tout cas elle sait de quoi
une vidéo parle et je pense qu'avec un
peu plus de travail s'est encore fait
sur son vote mais ferait très rapidement
tu peux savoir si la personne utilise le
conditionnel si la personne
utilisez mode et des marqueurs
nouvelliste et binic si la personne
parle de manière bienveillante
si la personne source de servir oxymore
il ya au nid dans tout ça parce qu'on
est un petit à petit et puis même un
truc qui est trop ironique je trouve ça
pas des diables sa dépendance à des
ponts pour king en général les gens qui
aiment bien le contenu tout ironique
mais papa déjà pour l'humanité forme
d'ironie cc66 à queue de l'ironie dans
une vidéo tension de chaîne youtube
c'est s'habituer à ce mode de pensée qui
me semble que mon papa désir avec ce cas
ça me dérange pas si ce genre de vidéos
et moins recommandées qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
oui mais toi tu es une personne dans un
espace social qui compte au clan
personnes avec des avis divergent donc
ouais de s'écarter de cette position là
est de se dire je pense ça avait quand
même mais je suis conscient que d'autres
personnes peuvent penser différemment
rey et le fait qu'on fasse société c'est
important que cette mon idée là elle
soit remise en contexte
non il ya les extrêmes oublié après pour
savoir exactement ce que l'ia devrait
faire qu'une question enfin c'est
vraiment le coeur de la discussion du
livre à venir que je vais écrire
et puis ça rend compte que je vais
courir pour noël les cadeaux et donc
voit ce que c'est vraiment tout un champ
de recherche est l'une des idées par
exemple c'est ce qu'on appelle en gros
l'idée de coups de basses essaie de
prendre en compte les préférences la
plupart des gens et de faire moyennant
un scrutin surtout sa place
donc si jamais un consensus balaya va
faire un truc qui correspond au
consensus
quel genre discrète en question mais
papa part pas pouvoir donner en fait
d'une certaine manière c'est le
sculpteur ultime c'est une femme
les scrutins ultime c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui on vote pour des
représentants d'autres gens veulent
voter pour des lois en suisse ils votent
pour des lois il faut des votations
produits loi et c'est très bien mais en
fait on a peu de choix à chaque fois tu
pouvais te dire en fait un scrutin idéal
il doit prendre beaucoup plus que ça
donc il faut lui donner beaucoup plus de
données du coût et finalisation de
beaucoup plus de données et puis tant
qu'à faire de voter sur un petit truc en
particulier pourquoi pas voter
directement sur nos préférences du monde
de la société d'attenté échelle quoi et
les coups ça c'est un peu le scot un
idéal que le scrutin sur vraiment les
préférences mentale de tous les gens sur
les différents états possibles du monde
en classe et à résoudre m2 ce serait
classe ça pourrait être ça sauf pour les
gens qui n'ont pas accès au scrutin ou
des gens qui pourrait imaginer de faire
des comptes de fer multiples qu'on
pourra voir plusieurs voient donc donc
il serait forcément cas dans ce genre de
situation ouais du couffo est robuste un
peu à tout ça et en prenant en compte
l'avis de tout le monde
il ya pas mal de deux façons de faire
sans doute mais une des idées de base ça
serait soit on essaie de quoi vider que
de demander l'avis de tout le monde et
voir de qualité et normand sur surtout
mon bon sens autant couper quelques uns
vient ensuite tu peux avoir un méta
modèle qui essaie d'imaginer voir ces
gens là sont similaires j'ai pris de
données sur ce mec-là mais du coup
probablement il aurait préféré ça il
devra sans doute et au tessin jusque
lors de deux modèles et du coup moi je
trouverais ça pour moi c'est un axe de
recherche prioritaires aujourd'hui est
de savoir comment concevoir ce genre de
système de collecte de préférence de
tout le monde
et tant qu'on a pas de solution
technique c'est assez difficile de
reprocher quoi que ce soit un youtube
parce que ce soit soit antérieure subit
aussi des gens qui bossent quoi
et puis c'est plus facile s'il ya une
solution simple à implémenter avec
laquelle il puisque aussi open source et
on peut vérifier tout le monde peut
contribuer c'est un petit peu l'idéal
vers lequel j'aimerais que la recherche
temps d'aujourd'hui notamment de
recherche on y voit la moitié nord
malaisie est bénéfique
c'est une petite une idée intéressante
après avoir pour moi en tout cas ça
mérite plus de réflexion à fournir un
avis plus ou moins tranchée pas
forcément trancher
juste un avis sur les têtes blondes
certains des arguments maison pertinents
j'ai 54 vidéo à ce sujet là bientôt un
livre si je couds de temps mais je ferai
l'effort que du coup est-ce quelque
chose que tu voudrais rajouter qu'il
fait chaud lui rajouter je pense qu'on a
on a abordé pas mal de sujets on le dit
on a fait la vie l'univers le reste on a
changé le monde
on a
elle est arrivée qu'est ce que c'est une
société souhaitable on a dit comment est
ce qu'on change le monde
maintenant faut se bouger les fesses et
mettre le doigt sur le postérieur et et
voilà enfin si encore des gens qui
écoutent à ce point de la discussion
enfin vous des warriors les gens ça
c'est fait que cinq heures et demie
messier à 5h30 pour écouter je vais
parler d'eux comme en janvier
ce nom c'est jose aussi s'il ya des gens
qui sont arrivés jusque-là sens qui paie
la vidéo félicitations vous allez tout
tout mon respect et merci de m
42 dans les commentaires et de laïcs et
les gens qui disent 42 voilà mais est-ce
qu'un message quel message clé tu
aimerais que les auditeurs retiennent un
message clé se dispersent et dure cinq
heures et demie de discussions il y à un
monde au dessus et au dessous de vous
vous faites partie de ce monde et ça
serait bien d'agir dessus de manière
bénéfique en comprenant ce monde et en
sachant qu'on peut agir dessus de
manière plus efficace que maintenant
donc c'est des réflexions que si chaque
personne n'avait cette réflexion
aujourd'hui de se dire que voilà on est
on n'est pas tout seul
no man is nigh l'homme comment commander
un nul homme nu loeb d'études il d'une
femme aussi je pense que wyeth une aile
laulala aulas est ce qu'on va vraiment
terminé c'est en cette blague
non voilà par deux intéressés vont au
monde posez vous des questions qu'on
n'arrêtait pas de me poser des questions
la mort des questions c'est la mort tout
court quoi et et voilà enfin
aimez vous les uns les autres voilà
c'est une idée qui dont l'efficacité a
été prouvée
c'est un truc qu'on répand depuis 2000
anges et jamais aucun prennent un coup
d'épongé mais est ce que tu vas finir
avec des recommandations de vidéos
livres podcast non moi j'ai à faire je
fais une petite liste là oui je parais
koala fait mes devoirs
alors bye évidemment l'un des podcasts
que je recommande c'est mindscape qui je
pense est un des meilleurs podcasts qui
aujourd'hui peut l'appeler le
probablement anglophone est allée f
je ne serai pas qu'ils vont voilà il ya
deux podcasts qui sont moins connus que
j'aimerais bien que j'aime bien répondre
il y en a un qui s'appelle flash forward
l'eau de rose
vite vite gp comment prononçons mais
c'est un podcast qui traite du futur et
de science fiction en général l'idée
c'est de partir d'une situation d'un
futur probable
et d'interroger des experts sur tous les
problèmes que ça peut poser comment
est-ce que ça peut être implémentée il
ya toujours un grand recul de
l'animatrice de la pohdh casse du
podcast sur sur tous ces sujets et c'est
vraiment vraiment très intéressant il y
en a un autre qui s'appelle of our avoir
opinion arles correct qu'il est fait par
anna ligne annalynne hewitt et une autre
dont dont j'ai oublié le nom qui est
importé sur la science fiction
donc c'est de la réflexion sur la
science fiction et le lien entre
science-fiction et société et
personnellement en tant que fan de
science-fiction les fans de société
pincé un peu
c'est un peu du nez arias moi c'est
yahia toujours tu étais toujours des
réflexions pertinentes je trouve qu'ils
sont pas mal alignée avec avec ce que je
pense
voilà c'est aussi pour ça que je les
écoute pour confirmer tout ce que je
pense savoir voilà il ya les fentes
plein de plâtre peint podcast canaille
alain que j'aime beaucoup que cbs des
podcasts history of art world
c'est un podcast qui raconte l'histoire
du monde depuis la préhistoire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et c'est un truc en
plusieurs centaines d'épisodes d'un
c'est un truc de malade et c'est un
historien qui fait ça je crois et il est
juste absolument incroyable enfin niveau
narration niveau storytelling niveau
fait aussi sa super intéressant ces
épisodes de vingt minutes à chaque fois
qu'ils sont thématiques si on veut
connaître l'histoire du monde de toutes
les civilisations bas c'est un bon
endroit pour commencer je pense
il ya un podcast qui les liait
thématiquement à sa qui s'appelle the
three stories aux philosophies without
any gap ce bon alors là le le mec qui
fait ça alors comment il s'appelle déjà
non j'ai oublié son nom donc certains
c'est un philosophe sans philosophe qui
parle de toute l'histoire de la
philosophie dans tout le monde entier il
s'est lancé dans une espèce de quête qui
est incroyable car j'ai jamais vu une de
une ampleur dans la diffusion des idées
qui est aussi grande pour un podcast
et donc voilà il va te faire tout tu
prends un continent est pas toute
l'histoire des idées depuis le début de
depuis le début de l'écriture enfin
c'est un truc de malade
et voilà ça c'est un type qui a une
vision de la philosophie assez
intéressante qui dit que la philosophie
c'est l'histoire des idées et j'ai un
point de vue qui est pas forcément
consensuel par des philosophes mais
c'est un bon personnellement ça me parle
mais voilà c'est super intéressant donc
ça c'est les papilles est anglais j'ai
deux podcasts français que j'aime
beaucoup
on a un qui s'appelle sismique qui parle
et qui parle de futurs aussi classe à
c'est un français qui interviewent des
pleins d'experts de plein de domaines
sur l'évolution de notre société à court
moyen et long terme
c'est des discussions long format ça
dure une heure au salon fort parmi nous
alléger oublié qu'on était sur le plus
long podcast du monde voilà et est donc
donc ça va qu'est ce que j'aime bien
aussi il y en a un dernier que j'ai
découvert tout récemment et qui est
juste incroyable qui s'appelle les
couilles sur la table et c'est un
patrice qui parle de masculinité
donc la ccc un podcast dans l'hôtel sais
c'est quoi être un mec au 21e siècle en
2019 et il ya passé c'est la
présentatrice va inviter pas mal de pas
mal de sociologues des historiens des
historiennes des gens qui parlent de
sexe des gens qui parlent de relations
de masculinité toxiques et de tous les
problèmes qui sont les la masculinité
aujourd'hui et je pense que beaucoup
problèmes de notre société actuelle sont
dues à la masculinité et sera plutôt sur
des certaine vision néfaste de la
masculinité et je pense que wes et c'est
un podcast qui est assez salvateur parce
que ils vont vraiment dans les détails
c'est vraiment toujours source est
toujours pertinent et jusqu'au fond du
poster on va jusqu'au fond du postérieur
exactement très littéralement d'ailleurs
et voilà cdp qu'est ce que j'aime par
des pépites ce que j'ai découvert
récemment quoi donc s'adapter pour les
podcasts les bouquins qui m'ont le plus
marqué récemment
donc il y en a un qui s'appelle où
l'évolution des check off de tim burton
et andrew watson
donc ça parle de toute l'histoire de la
terre depuis le début de la terre et de
toutes les révolutions qui ont permis à
la terre d'accéder à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
c'est un bouquin qui s'adresse pas au
grand public c'est un bouquin qui
s'adresse à des étudiants
des étudiants en sciences généralement
je le mettrais un niveau niveau l1 l2
qui est un bouquin incroyable parce
qu'il décrit vraiment comment est-ce
qu'un chercheurs des sciences du système
terre essaye de comprendre la terre
aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce qu'est ce qui constitue une
révolution majeure dans une transition
majeure dans l'histoire de la terre et
qu'elle comment on peut quantifier notre
impact sur le monde depuis depuis le
début l'histoire de l'humanité et je
trouve ça vraiment fascinant qu'il ya
vraiment une approche très rigoureuse
très pratique et une prose qui est juste
remarque anne fin c'est des gens bien
pas fou il faut les lire il away plus
pluvieux que que ça yaya phishing
systems de donner la meadows alors
donnez la v2 il faut ça c'est l'une des
trois chercheurs qui ont sont à
l'origine du rapport sur les limites de
la croissance
ils étaient publiés dans les années 70
avec le club de rome donc l'idée c'est
d'avoir une vision systémique du monde
de promouvoir la pensée par système est
de promouvoir la pensée d'un système
complexe je pense que d'un point de vue
pratique moi ça a changé ma vision du
monde
vraiment ça a changé la manière dont je
vois les choses dont je vois les
événements du ronde de les remettre en
contact dans des systèmes complexes et
de les voir à plusieurs échelles et tout
c'est toute cette dynamique à plusieurs
échelles de temps et l'espace
ça m'a beaucoup aidé quoi et c'est un
livre qui est très imagée avec beaucoup
d'exemples de savoir comment est-ce que
les gens qui pensent à système complexe
aujourd'hui pensent les systèmes
complexes aujourd'hui et pour le coup
c'est un délit ce qui m'a le plus marqué
c'est à dix dernières années
intellectuellement
donc voila et je vais en citer un
dernier alors j'ai déjà c'était of women
and the big pink moon qui est aussi sûr
sur ces questions de l'histoire de la
terre et 2 et 2 de notre impact et de c1
c'est un bouquin qui introduit l'idée
d'un certain une certaine vision de
l'écologie qui s'appelle l'écho
modernisme donc qui dit que alors oui on
est à l'origine de beaucoup de
perturbations dans le système terre mais
on en est aussi conscient et du coup ça
nous donne une responsabilité d'agir sur
le système terre de manière positive
parce qu'on est les seuls capables de le
faire parce qu'on est les voilà on est
on est sur le monde et sur le siège du
conducteur
on sait pas conduire mais on est quand
même sur la route est lancé à 90 km 130
donc on a intérêt à apprendre à tourner
le volant et à la freiner si on veut si
on veut agir manière positive sur le sur
le système et ça c'est un bouquin
vraiment intéressant ça parle de plein
de choses de la vie dans l'univers de la
recherche d'intelligence extraterrestre
de l'anthropocène et après ça c'est un
bouquin qui m'a marqué et huit derniers
la des religieux à bout de bras sa fille
au goût de vos souffrances
le dernier c'est un gars qui s'appelle
fact foule naissent alors qui c'est le
seul qui est traduit en français en tout
la liste j'ai très bien français ouais
il est traduit récemment donc fast food
fournaise de hans rosling illico sous
titres français cabaye s'appelle fans
foulent natation française
ouais c'est pas beaucoup ils n'ont pas
traduit d'ailleurs parce que j'ai
demandé aux auteurs s'ils avaient
traduit bondi ouais on va dire quelque
chose comme pleine conscience ou quelque
chose comme ça mais en fait ça n'a
jamais été traduit donc s'est fait
rouler à 100 français est donc en france
l'insee
c'est un mec qui a fait beaucoup dans la
promotion d'une vision rationnelle du
monde
en fait paris il a fait pas mal de tête
talk de documentaires sur comment
comment voir notre monde aujourd'hui de
voir que le monde ne va pas si mal
auto aussi mal qu'on le dit il se sert
de données pour ça des statistiques sur
le monde et voilà donc dans
l'utilisation des statistiques sur le
monde pour par les données
démographiques il est donné sur
l'illettrisme sur la mortalité infantile
de se servir de ces données là pour
essayer de brosser un tableau factuels
sur le monde qui nous entoure
je trouvais ça vraiment intéressant et
c'est un bouquin qui donne des petits
algorithmes manteau pour pouvoir penser
de manière plus plus fiable au niveau
individuel alors c'est un bon gars qui a
été il vous faut être critique par
rapport à ce bouquin parce que c'est un
bien qui a été jugé trop positifs et
parfois à raison parce que on se
concentre sur certains sujets plutôt que
d'autres mais ça reste un bouquin que je
pense important à lire parce que c'est
des idées qui sont pas assez répandue à
mon sens qua non genre il ya eu 10 de
steven pinker way qui nous estimons
piqueur je suis un peu très sceptique et
sur scène avec chic et notamment les
tchèques qui ont peur de vieillir
ouais ouais est-ce que c'est efficace a
beaucoup critiqué ce livre ouais c'est
pareil il mime pickers il me désarçonne
un petit peu parce que c'est vraiment
c'est quelqu'un qui est connu pour faire
du cherry picking quoi comprendre des
études qui vont dans son sens et pas les
autres
et c'est quelqu'un qui est très
influente dans les mouvements
nationalistes et ça maintenant autant
voilà je ne sais pas j'ai jamais lu de
ses bouquins c'est un des gros pavé tu
peux tu peux qu'aller une porte avec mr
tu as he gets engins sont aussi
sceptiques qui se lève à chaque fois que
j'entends steven figure parler quoi
réplique slate qui était pas mal mais
dernier
ouais bah c'était déjà le cas dans deux
bêtes alors de better angels à mort
naturelle ans apparemment il était aussi
critiqué pour ça dans sa bibliographie
de citer que les études qui vont dans
son sens
et ben voilà les en plus c'est une
critique est ce qu'un moment is it
stuart au sol il prend un goût de se
battre seul qui dit que le vin qu'il ya
le potentiel de faire beaucoup de bien
tant que genre et du coup il ne lui a
fallu que du coup elle même les experts
dire de aucun risque il ya parce que
tout ira bien à ses pairs alors que ce
soit entre sun et des plus promis non à
dire que
il y appose ducrocq risque ouais bah
merci beaucoup
sébastien c'est à toi pour la balade
riche discussions et merci pour les
auditeurs qui sont ils se sont pas
endormis jusque là je pense que c'est la
plus longue discussion que j'ai jamais
eue sur n'importe quel sujet allez on a
parlé de n'importe quel sujet donc assez
je me savais pas que ça fait encore au
niveau de ta bd et absolue mais bon ça
n'est pas loin des palaces à neuf
proches on n'aura pas le palmarès le
plus long podcast mais surtout grâce à
être divisé en deux du coup il ya là
rien de très impressionnant il ya deux
épisodes de moins de trois heures moi ce
que je trouve impressionnant c'est des
gens qui m'arrive ans jusque là vraiment
se battre merci à jean est admirable
merci je vais d'ailleurs si vous avez
des commentaires sur tout ce qu'on a dit
qu'ils sont constructifs et qui pourrait
alimenter la discussion et qui sont
sources et avec des arguments pertinents
n'hésitez pas parce que moi je les dis
je lis tous alors quand je fais des
interventions je lis tous les
commentaires et j'ai besoin de ces idées
là c'est des idées que je dénonce pour
la première fois en public pour
certaines et de savoir à quel point
c'est pertinent ou pas moi ça me permet
de sortir de ma bulle
pour avoir de meilleures idées donc
voilà j'encourage à faire ça si le coeur
vous en dit s'il ya des commentaires
vont aider directement à sébastien bon
set paquet avec ça si c'est pour dire
que l'essai le plus beau ouais je viens
de voir cela merci beaucoup en tout cas
sébastien et merci à tout le monde
à une prochaine fois probablement que